[Music]
now
one hi folks my name is Lauren Alia
Welcome to our very first one-of-a-kind
ton event EV this is called uh python
from A to Z and I am your host Lauren
olja later on today I will be joined by
my co-host Jane Harman uh you may know
me from such Antics as the Piata Global
pub quiz or the of uh you know the very
first one of 2020 our very first Piata
Global or the uh uh executive co-chair
of the uh when what was that of Pi data
NYC 2018 and 2019 and or you may know me
as one of the uh organizers of NYC
Python and so um I'm really excited to
be here today to help raise money for
Num Focus num focus is a 501c3 nonprofit
Global nonprofit dedicated to uh uh open
science that is inclusive and and
reproducible and so it's really
important for the pi data uh ecosystem
that's the ecosystem of tools that we
use for scient open source scientific
Computing and so I just wanted to remind
you that we are live this is a live
event uh anything can happen on live TV
uh my dog might write run by or things
like that and we uh we're really hoping
to have a lot of fun here today so um
without further Ado actually let me go
ahead and share my
screen can you see that
okay that's very
funny okay great so we are here to
benefit num Focus where open C where
open code equals better science and
we're going to hear a little bit more
about num focus in just a
moment
this Telethon is sponsored by don't use
this code uh don't use this code is my
employer I'm a director there and uh we
we really believe in giving back to the
community the thing about don't use this
code is that we are a training and
education company uh specializing in
Python services so we do Consulting uh
python training and uh uh events such as
this where we give back to the oh I'm
being told I don't have a screen being
shared one second
here let me just take a look at what
happened
here live TV folks live TV Lauren this
is the ghost from behind the scenes
let's make sure we get all the mistakes
out in the first just couple of seconds
just to make sure that the next four
hours goes as smoothly as possible
because this is live TV Anything could
happen oh my goodness that's true that's
true
all right well we didn't miss much in
the slides anyway because it's just a
couple of logos um so here's the num
Focus uh
logo here's the don't use this code
logo and I also wanted to thank uh all
of our early donors so um our early
donors are listed here if you donated
more than $100 you get a shout out so
thank you vuto for your $100 donation
and also thank you to uh smart one
for $100 as well um really uh this is
great our first stretch goal is $750 and
so we are nearly halfway there really
appreciate everyone who's donating if
you haven't donated yet you have uh the
next four hours to do so and you might
get a shout out as
well um the link to donate is on our
tiltify and so if you're watching this
on tiltify the Donate now is right there
if you're watching this on Eventbrite
then uh you need to scroll down to where
it says donate now and donate there and
if you happen to be watching this on
YouTube live then uh the link is in the
description of the
channel and I'm being told that we have
62 people watching live so if you do a
little bit of math if everyone did uh
you know $5 donation we would probably
reach our first stretch goal in a matter
minutes let me tell you a little bit
about our fabulous prizes so don't who
give between $100 and and $249 will
receive a discount code to an upcoming
don't use this code seminar in a
matching amount to what you donate to
num Focus um so we are happy to credit
your donation towards our next class
additionally donors at this level will
be entered into a drawing where three
winners will receive a grab grab bag of
stickers I know that you all really miss
the stickers from our Live inperson
Events uh in The New Normal we we're
having to adapt and so uh for the
virtual virtual events that don't have
stickers uh we're we're trying to make
up for
that the first five donors who give
between 250 and $4.99 will receive a
grab bag of 15 project stickers and also
uh be uh be entered into a three- winner
raffle and everyone in this category
will receive a discount code to the next
Pi data Conference of their choice
and also the first three donors who give
over $500 will receive a numb Focus
t-shirt and the remainder of these
donors at this level will be entered
into a three- winner raffle and everyone
in this category will receive a discount
code to an upcoming Pi data Conference
of their choice whether that is the pi
data Global series or the uh uh P data
inperson conferences when we return to
inperson
conferences all donors who donate over a
thousand dollar here we're starting to
get ambitious but I I hope that you're
feeling generous today and maybe after
you see James sweat a little bit it'll
help open your pocket we will see but
donors who donate over ,000 will receive
a free ticket to the next uh P data
Conference of their choosing whether
that's in person or virtual and at the
$5,000 level uh don't use this code will
submit a poll request to have line art
of your face entered into the standard
matplot lib Gallery uh we ever see word
from the maintainers of matplot lib that
there are no guarantees that this poll
request will be
merged and uh donors who give over
$10,000 or more will receive a free
ticket to our next uh Advanced case
studies class in March that is being
hosted by don't use this code as well as
private tea time with James during the
event so this is a this this is
definitely the woohoo level if you feel
like giving $10,000 or more today um uh
you will definitely get a personal phone
call from
us all right I think that's it for my
slides other than just to let you know
that we have a hashtag it is cjames
sweat and so please help us have this
conversation either on the YouTube uh uh
live comments you can comment there live
to be part of the conversation or you
can also reach us on Twitter using the
cjames sweat hashtag we will be
monitoring this uh all of the best stuff
will hopefully be forwarded to me and
you might even hear your name or comment
read
online so with that I would actually
love to introduce to you well before we
go to our our special guest I was going
to say I'd love to introduce you to our
special guest but actually I I want to
introduce you to James first so um James
why don't you come off
Shadow hey everybody this is James
Powell I serve as chair of the num
focused board of directors I also served
as vice president for pida since
2014 I believe
2015 and I've been told that num focus
is supporting open source scientific
Computing but couldn't do it without you
and without your donations and your
support and your volunteerism so Lauren
and I have decided to volunteer
ourselves this Saturday to help you on
live TV convince yourselves that it's a
worthy cause worth giving to I'm not
quite sure what I've signed up for I
think Lauren's going to tell me what
it's all about in just a moment but I
wanted to thank Lauren for helping to
put this in put this all together and
thank num Focus for all of the support
that it's given all of us who use the
open source scientific Computing tools
whether in the Piata ecosystem or in the
r or juliia
ecosystem thanks so much James and now I
would love to introduce uce you all to
our very first guest uh we are honored
here to be accompanied by Leah silin
executive director of num
Focus thanks Lauren and thank thanks
James and thanks um do not use this code
for this very outof the-box um idea for
fundraising in a year that it is um so
so much needed so thank you um for the
whole team for your efforts and for
putting putting this together we um we
appreciate each of you
greatly as they said this is a
fundraiser for Num focus and um I'll
give just a kind of brief overview of
num Focus um I want to specifically kind
of focus on the focus on the impact that
that n focus is making through our work
in the tools that you use and the tools
that you depend on num focus is here to
support open- source scientific
Computing tools to make that research
possible um to make sure those tools are
um are on a Healthy Growth trajectory to
make sure they are
sustainable and um that need that
happens through support um we provide
some vital services to contributors and
that's the area I'm going to focus first
our services to contributors we also
feel like it's greatly important to um
also support the user community so we
have programs that um are also targeted
to make sure the users of our tools are
um are supported and have communication
with the contributors maintainers of the
tools um in different educational
initiatives but back to um our impact on
tools themselves as far as the
contributors um working with the
maintainers and project leads very
closely to to ensure what they have and
um as a reminder num Focus has um 40
plus sponsored projects as well as um
approximately 40 Affiliated projects
that we serve um we are the legal entity
and fiscal sponsor for our sponsored
projects and these are foundational
Tools in scientific research um they are
used um in across many domains in
science
um research um fora lately um in covid
research and
Analysis um and whether we are talking
about our tools that are used um in
astrophys astrophysics or by um
astronomers for groundbreaking
Innovations uh we have Senpai just to
name a few of the tools in that area um
used for research for directs direct
observations of the Sun and heliosphere
heliosphere um astropy provides
infrastructure to facilitate research on
a global scale by professional
astronomers um and a new tool and our
new project Tardis um is analyzing
exploding stars and many of our projects
are also involved um in um astronomy in
in that aspect of scientific research
our our tools are also foundational in
industry data science machine learning
across all domains um as well as in
education and widely used by um
governments around the world so it's
important that our tools are um are
sustainable are growing and we support
that internal um project infrastructure
so um the projects themselves provide
their technical direction we are
supporting them on other sides we work
on their um Financial Administration on
legal needs um which are great across
our open- source um projects that we
support um many legal questions come
into play and we provide services um in
that respect we also Grant um provide
Grant Management full Grant Management
which is huge so we make it possible for
projects to be able to have funding
coming in and uh how can we support
those grants of our projects you know we
have 40 plus tools multiple grants on
projects so um there's a lot of work
involved providing that um that service
we also um help projects with um needed
infrastructure um digital infrastructure
that they need making sure they have
tools for meetings and for um their user
communities as well as contributor
communities to be able to be
supported um I'm trying to think if
there's any other um on projects we also
just um Community networking um projects
that are part of num Focus are part of a
Global Network and making those
introductions and um connections for
project um Integrations and networking
around the world um we also provide that
as well for um project community support
and then the other aspect that we uh
really focus on for projects is
promotion promotion we want to help
promote our projects we want everyone to
know about them um we want to um
increase the user base and make sure
that we have a renewable contributor
base as well so that um making sure um
the projects are promoted and um even
working on projects with branding and um
those kind of services are also um
integral so that's um kind of where we
are on the um contributor side on that
Community um I guess direction we
provide Educational Services through our
events um we've also are introducing num
Focus Academy which will be an online
learning platform which is in its very
very early stages um that's supported by
Sloan
Foundation we also are um work with
communities on Dei support we have a lot
of initiatives that we're working our
diversity and scientific Computing
committee has worked um to make sure
scientific conferences have a guideline
and resource book that they can use and
we're working on um also putting
resources together and more guidance for
online um online events also we have an
event team that is able to work with our
projects on events as well as our event
series Pi data um so we support projects
on both project events as well well as
um n Focus organized events and I also
wanted to mention U we are just kicking
off a Project based on understanding
contributor diversification and
retention in in open- Source scientific
Computing projects um we are grateful
for the um the support by the Moore
Foundation to be able to kick this
project off um we have brought in a
developer Advocate and project manager
for this and we'll be doing in-depth
research on our projects um with the
ultimate goal of providing guidelines
that will be disseminated across open-
Source projects for contributor
diversification and retention so we're
super excited about that so those are
some of the things we do as you support
and focus um make donations through this
um incredible effort that do not use
this code is launching as well as
donations through the website um these
are the kinds of Serv services that
you're supporting for projects and for
the Greater Community on a whole um we
work really hard we have a staff of
eight um we could use a staff of 10 even
12 so um and during this year of 2020 a
year that has um we've faced great
uncertainty um budget wise um the funds
are especially crucial crucial so we
thank you for um for your help and your
ongoing
support wow great thank you so much Leah
it num focus is even more involved than
I even realized it sounds very
expensive and it sounds like the kind of
thing that uh you know if everyone could
pitch in uh uh we could get some really
great work done it's incredible what num
focus is
doing thanks
Lauren so do you think um do you think
James is ready for what he has ahead um
26 lightning talks in the next you know
not even four hours
now um three hours 40 I have complete
confidence complete confidence in him I
know uh his um yeah his coding will be
um as well as um increasing everyone's
knowledge and they're probably going to
learn a lot um also um James has a great
way of being in entertaining as as he
codes so I think I think this will be um
yeah a great opportunity for people to
like I said to to learn something um see
James kind of think on think on the spot
which he is also excellent at so yeah
I'm looking forward to it fantastic well
thank you so much again Leah for being
here and uh um I think we better uh hop
right into it
James I think the good news Lauren is
that it'll be entertaining whether I
succeed or fail and so thank you for
that fantastic overview of num Focus
Leah and I wanted to add two more things
that you do at num Focus to support the
community number one I think we've
forgotten about the stickers uh very
very important how many stickers do we
print every year probably thousands upon
thousands and number two even harder and
more important is we have 40 Projects
and they're each run by very talented
very principled and very opinionated
core developers and as part of your work
you bring all of these people together
align them on a common set of principles
and convince them that we can do more if
we build together than we could build if
we worked alone and that is not an easy
job it's a very hard job you may think
I'm difficult to work with but imagine
having to work with 40 core developers
from 40 different projects my goodness I
can't imagine how much work that must
be
they're great they make my job um yeah
very very rewarding we have an
incredible
community so Lauren we're ready to jump
right into it I think so um does
everyone here know what a lightning talk
is I think I I think I know it's a talk
where you get electrocuted if you don't
manage to get a good point out in a
short period of time is that correct
correct correct and so I've got my
buzzer no no it's not it's we will not
be electrocuting James today but a
lightning talk is a short five minute
technical talk um today our theme is the
alphabet and James do you know what you
will be coding for each of the
letters well I do know what the alphabet
is I believe there are at least 24 or 25
letters in it I'm not sure if there's
more I don't quite know what you want me
to do for each letter so why don't I
write these down and you let me know
what you want me to do okay great so
we'll do it in in blocks so we'll do I
guess five letters five first five
letters to start so let's decide what
you're going to do for a b c d and e
right so just off the top of my head um
if I remember correctly A is for apple b
is for ball and C is for I think I
didn't do that for school today we're
doing this python style this is the
pythonic alphabet okay there we
go so A is for async o wait A is for
nump a
range A is for any or all maybe I'll do
numpy do array then okay I think that
sounds good okay b b what could B be
before
built-ins
breakpoint byes vers yeah pretty cool
yeah
okay what about uh see collections
collections. counter collections. chain
map comprehension syntax is really
important in
Python collections. ABC and instance
check could I do context managers you
could do all right all right you can do
context managers okay it's
classic and then CT there's so many good
c-words yeah there are we might have to
do just only the letter c for the next
one of these 26 around just that one
letter
I'm sure people would tune in for the
2060s how about d d is for well
decorators obviously descriptors data
classes I think data classes is pretty
easy I think that's a newer feature that
people want to hear about
default did class all right
great e e is
for
El
elephants exactly yeah
I think that that works
well so I got my first five do you want
me to get started yeah it is 2:24 local
time I think uh let's go ahead and get
started here and I got five minutes per
five minutes per talk don't the talks
have to be interesting the talks do have
to be interesting that is a requirement
code have to work the code does have to
work I expect you to run it live on the
screen okay well let's see what I can do
you see now how why why you might be
sweating by the end of this well I'm in
a climate controlled room here so I've
I've jacked the AC all the way up so
we'll see we'll see all right fantastic
um before we do launch uh I'm being told
that we have a first trivia question and
the first person on Twitter to answer it
by mentioning us at
dcore tring and using the cjames sweat
hashtag will get a shout out at our next
next break um first trivia question is
what inspired the coding language python
to be called
python I think that should be fairly
easy but uh go ahead and find your
Twitter open it up be the first one to
shout it out and you will get a shout
out on this live stream when we come
back I also did want to give you just a
quick uh fundraising update that we are
now halfway towards our goal uh no
almost still almost halfway towards our
goal we've raised $350 so go ahead and
click that donate button if you like
what you see while James is coding what
happens when we hit
750 oh uh there's a big reveal for that
I don't have it quite in front of me so
it'll it'll be a surprise reveal
fantastic wait that's horrible no I
don't like that at
all I'm sure it'll be great for
you take it away okay enough talk let's
get coding let me share my screen with
you and I'll switch over to my view here
I think we're starting with the numpy
array is what we agreed on and so I got
five minutes to tell you something
interesting about numpy array well uh
for those of you who aren't familiar
with the library numpy numpy provides
you with a very interesting underlying
type which is the numpy and Dray and if
you look at an umpai and Dray it may
look like a collection like any other
like you used list before but one of the
things that you may see with the numpy
Dr is it has certain characteristics
that are not really possible to
replicate in pure python that make it
particularly suitable for high-speed
scientific or numeric Computing let me
show you an example of this um if we
have a python list would say the number
is one two three and another python list
with the numbers four five and six and
we were to perform an operation on these
two lists for example we were to add
them together the result of that
operation that we would see would not be
an element-wise computation it would be
some kind of structure-wise computation
fundamentally the python list is an
opaque collection of items it doesn't
really know what it contains and so all
the operations that you perform on a
python list are done structure-wise this
would be what you might call
concatenation and if you were to take
this same list here and you to perform
another operation at like multiply times
a scalar value you might think oh is
this going to multiply all the op all
the elements by three nope this is still
a structure-wise operation it means
repetition so we'll see this just
repeats the structure it's just repeated
addition after all whereas if you took a
numpy and Dr array and you'd perform
this same operations on it you see
something slightly different let's take
these two python lists and we'll put
them into numpy and Dr type I like to
call numpy and Dr type a restricted
computation domain and I think that's
actually quite interesting here because
what you can see is I'm actually
starting with the python list and python
integers and I'm putting them into a
structure when I put them into a
structure the UNP and D array actually
unboxes your python integers one thing
that you may already be aware of when it
comes to a python integer is that a
python integer supports automatic
promotion which means that there is is
really no maximum python integer right
you can keep exponentiating this as
large as you have memory for and it just
keeps working whereas this numpy and D
array that I just created is actually
machine typed it is no longer a boxed
integer it's now some unboxed type it
actually is in this particular case an
N64 and in addition to it being an unbox
type and a machine type and importantly
enough contiguous in memory operations
per formed on this ND array are
mathematical operations when I add two
ND arays together it adds them element
wise when I multiply an ND aray it does
it element wise as well and so what you
can see is this num by and D aray is a
very interesting type because it
provides you with something that the
core python built-in types don't provide
you with it provides you with a
structure that is aware of its contents
provides you with a structure which has
control over its contents from the
perspective of memory as in these are
all machine typed contiguous values and
it provides you with something slightly
different because if you think about a
python list the python list has a
certain set of characteristics for it
the python list has a fixed shape but it
has a dynamic size whereas a numpy and
Dray has
a has a dynamic shape and a fixed size
and I'll show you what I mean by that if
you take a look at an ump and D you look
at the internals of a numine d right
internally what it really is is a
raw view of memory and you can actually
ask this nump indray what is the block
of raw memory that you reference and you
can see this numpy and D array with the
values one two and three is actually
that particular memory location on this
machine and if you ask the numpy and D
array tell me a little bit about how
you're interpreting that memory you can
see that npy and D array has the ability
to tells you oh these are a bunch of
n64s and so what you could actually do
with an unpay is you could perform
something that you can't really do in
Python there's really only one similar
notion of what I'm about to do in pure
python which is swapping out the class
on an object but here I can do something
quite interesting I can take some values
and I can cast them what I can do is I
can take a block of raw memory and I can
tell numpy uhuh these aren't in 64s
they're in eights there's not three of
them there's actually 24 of them what
you can think is the nump andd array is
this raw view of memory that gives you
the ability to do mathematical types
that can control those types that can
perform no Dynamic dispatch on
aggregated operations on machine typed
unbox types they're contiguous in memory
and it has this interpretive layer on
top of it where that gives you the
ability to say what is the dtype of this
and what is the shape and the what is
the shape and the strides of this and so
one of the cheap things you can do with
an npy and Dray is you can reshape it so
I can say this is a 2 by two structure
if I start off with four elements in
this and this is a free operation a list
is always some linear structure of
elements but you can add elements you
you can't add to the NP it's a raw view
of memory but you can tell it to be of
any shape that you want it to be and
let's remove that line and there we go
so I think that's a I hope I did well
let me move over to B boy that that took
I shouldn't have spent all that energy
on a now I have no energy left so let me
go to B um I'll reset my timer
and reset my timer and reset my screen
and we'll go to B I shouldn't put that
much energy into a there we go there's
my B reset my timer and let's go okay b
b is for breakpoint now you may you may
or may not know this but in Python 3.7
there was a new built-in added which is
the breakpoint built-in uh prior to
python 3.7 you had the ability to within
the standard Library debug some code
using pdb I actually prefer ipdv for
these purposes because I like the
IPython kernel a little bit better but
I'll give you an example let's say say
we have some code here and this code has
a bug in it and if I execute this code
it'll show me that there's a division by
zero here and one thing that
historically we might do is we might say
you know accept some
exception and here from pdb import
postmortem and run a postmortem
debugging on this now this isn't going
to work exactly with my auto Runner so
I'll just run this script
directly and we got to spell python
correctly there we go and you can see
accept exception
we go and I have a debugger and I can go
up and down and I can take a look at the
state of this thing well in addition to
being able to do postmortem debugging
what I might also want to be able to do
is I might also want to be able to put
specific break points so I could say
from pdb import set trace and I could
set a trace on some particular line of
code and you can see with my auto Runner
it's not going to work quite as well as
I'd like it to but you can see uh here I
have to invoke F to make this work there
we go and see I have a break point here
and I can can see roughly where I am in
the code well in Python 3.7 they added a
breakpoint instruction to do the same
thing and it has a corresponding bite
code so if I look at the dis assembly of
H I should
see let's continue there we go I should
see and let's uh move this above the
invocation of this thing I should see
this
thing
oops I should see this thing here and
you can see I actually sorry there was
no corresponding uh B code additor it's
just a call function uh and the reason
that it's a call function is that you
can actually swap out what the
breakpoint is and so you can go into the
CIS module and you can set the
breakpoint function to whatever you want
it to be I think it's like this or it's
breakpoint or breakpoint hook so let's
take a look at what it
is and it's called breakpoint hook so I
can set this to any breakpoint hook and
one cute thing I could do do is I could
probably write my own breakpoint hook
that does not cause this thing to
terminate but instead gets the outer
frames of the current frame and just
iterates through them so I could say for
f in this print dur F.F frame and I have
to really remember it's a good thing
that I have we call this breakpoint hook
and we have a breakpoint there and we
invoke it very good and this is uh
this is CIS that we do there there we
go and that was our breakpoint and I got
to see what's in here f. locals there we
go so what I could
do is instead of actually calling my pdb
which is what the default is for
breakpoint hook I could do the following
every time I hit an exception I could
and I'm going to skip the first and the
last one so we skip this just to make
that work and here I'll put this around
and try accept so I don't get that nasty
error
message there we
go and what I could do if I really
wanted to is and I'll remove this here I
could set up a breakpoint hook that
every time I hit you know this
breakpoint hook just prints out the
state of the current stack and so here
if I were to pass some extra variables
in
here you can see it'll print out all the
local variables let's do yal x x 2 we'll
do y here we'll pass y here we'll do Z =
y^2 we'll pass Z in here we'll pass Z in
here and then we'll divide Z by zero now
here this will still we'll just return
that because we don't care about the
error and there we go and so what we
should be able to do with this is
trigger our code with the break point
and let's make sure there's no bugs in
this so here we call G oh we have to
pass in a value here there we go and you
can see I can get the local state and if
I wanted to because of Python's Rich
runtime I could even get the frame
F name is that what it is no I got to
remember what the what's on this thing
we have the frame I think it's the
function name so here we do f. function
Dot and we could see what function we're
in and I think I can see the line number
as well so I could tell
you where my code
went line
number yeah there we go so you can see
what function I'm in where my code went
and the local state and so you can do
some really neat things with breakpoint
you can set your own custom breakpoints
you can C your own particular logic
there doesn't necessarily need to stop
your code and so what you could think of
is this breakpoint gives you some
arbitrary instrumentation Point within
your
code okay that's B now let's move on to
C which is our context managers and I
think I'm making pretty good time
because I haven't run out of too much
time yet and so let's switch over to the
context manager now context managers are
one of my favorite features in Python
and the reason why I like context
managers is I think that it is a way in
which you can convey to somebody who is
semi invested or Semite technical some
mechanics of house the code works for
and what I mean by semi invested is
there's oftentimes the case that when we
work with somebody in an environment
they care about the results of our code
but they don't necessarily care about
the process that we took to get there
but they still have some positive
contribution that they can make as part
of the code they can tell us something
like oh your approach is wrong or oh you
know the business situation has changed
very slightly and one of the great
things about python is that python tries
to afford a particular readability it
tries to conform to a particular notion
of readability so that somebody who is
not as technical as you might be as a
python expert or not as invested in the
particular mechanics of your solution
can still follow along and so I think
the context manager does that quite well
because you can think let me do this
with an example like this let's say some
fake DB API you know I have some connect
and a canonical example of this might be
something like this I connect to a
database and here I might say okay with
db.
transaction you know and here I might
get the
transaction and here I might do
something like you know uh db. execute
some particular SQL here and here and I
have two operations here and I do
something like this and you could think
that somebody who doesn't really know
what a context manager is or doesn't
really you know have a very clear sense
of how these Contex managers were
implemented could easily tell the
difference between this and this they'd
say oh this one's not being done inside
the transaction or they could tell the
difference between this and this they
could say oh these are being done inside
the transaction and so we have a
transaction within a transaction and so
what I really like about the context
manager is the way that it can convey to
somebody in a very simple sense what the
code is trying to do and they can give
some feedback for you they can say oh
these two operations should be done
automically within the transaction in a
very similar sense I'll show you a very
simple context manager that we can write
and it's may be something useful because
we may want want to use it later on uh I
write this context manager from scratch
all the time now I don't tend to write
context managers directly using the
enter and exit object model mechanism
because I find it's a little bit too
tedious and I'm oftentimes coding with
only two minutes two and a half minutes
of time left and so I have to go as
quickly as I possibly can and so what I
tend to do is I tend to use context Libs
context manager decorator in order to
adapt a generator into a context manager
which makes total sense because if you
think about it a generator is a
mechanism for sequencing operations what
it is is a way to take some computation
and add some structuring to that
computation and a context manager is
really just a metaphor for doing
something before and something after
some strict sequencing of two operations
not an arbitrary number of operations so
really the two of these oper the two of
these structures in Python really
comport very well they fit together very
well but let me write my context manager
here you may not know but the time
module has a performance counter that
allow is a monotonic counter here let's
do a finally let's uh do do something
like this we'll do start equals perf
counter and this begins to show
something very interesting so if I have
time I'll show you something that I
really like about this generator
formulation uh we'll say elapsed and
we'll see Greek letter Capital delta T
stop minus start point2 F seconds and
here uh Greek capital letter Delta
probably sorry I don't know my Unicode
names off the top of my head we'll pull
in sleep from the
time module and we'll just see if this
thing
works so with timed sleep of
one sleep of one here we go let's see if
that worked and we need to give this the
message so we probably need to put the
message here and let's just format that
slightly nicer there we go so here we
could
do this is a some section and you can
see you know if you wrote some code like
this they somebody could look at this
and say these three things are all under
this timer but this one section of your
code is only under this timer here and
we'll format this a little bit nicer
there we go now there's one more thing
that I want to share with you I don't
know if I can do this in the remaining
20 seconds I have but if we were to
write this as a class the way that it
would look is something like this we'd
have to write the
enter and we'd have to write the exit
and we'd have to store these things on
the class body itself and what you can
see is we have an implicit sequencing
here obviously because it's the context
manager but we also have some data flow
and control flow which Step goes before
which one which other one and which how
the data moves between this and it turns
out that in this object model that
control flow is not very well let's see
think we turn self oh no no this thing
needs a in
it so we have to do self. message equals
message think we're almost out of time
but what you can see is we're passing
passing some information through the
class in order to make this thing work
and it's not very clear how that
information proceeds we have the self do
message it comes into the class and it
comes out of the class it is often the
case that a generator formulation or
more specifically a co- routine
formulation takes a implicitly sequenced
sequence of operations that are in some
kind of class API and it linearizes them
in the source text so you can see the
control flow and the data flow hopefully
we'll have a chance to look at this in a
future lightning talk but unfortunately
I'm out of time on that one so I think I
got to go to data classes next and I'm
getting pretty good at switching over so
maybe I can take just one deep breath
before I start my I think I'm on four of
five I'm almost completely out of energy
so hopefully we can just adjourn now I
think four hours of time has passed so
uh sorry folks ton over but let me take
a deep breath and we'll go right
into Data classes data classes are
something that were added fairly
recently in Python I think they were
added in python
3.7 and as you may have seen before you
know it's just another shorthand for
writing a class one of the things that I
find is uh I am often writing code with
a focus on time to Market I just need to
write some prototype you know as quickly
as possible and if I have any live
coding skills the reason I have live
coding skill is the two types of things
that I do for work are either corporate
uh training where you have to show
something to somebody very quickly or
some kind of Consulting and if you're
building a prototype you want to show
somebody what that prototype does in
Live code as quickly as you can so you
want to be able to sketch things out
very quickly and if that's your
perspective then you what you want is
you want some kind of helpers for being
able to build reasonable structures as
quickly as possible and so the data
class really to me fits into a trio of
three common metaprogramming mechanisms
for building classes really quickly and
the three are the data class the enum
from the enum module and the name Tool
from the collections module and what's
really interesting about these is they
all three of them use different
mechanisms for meta programming this is
a class descriptor mechanism so this is
a class descriptor let's see if I can
spell class directly this is a meta
class-based mechanism and this is a eval
based mechanism or at least historically
it was an eval based mechanism but my
goal here is to show you a little bit
more about this data class it looks like
my timer hasn't started yet so I'm gonna
shut my timer down to about 180 seconds
remaining and I'll just guess that I
spent a couple minutes there already so
let's see uh the way that you use data
class is you push onto some class some
behavior and you can see this is a
convenience mechanism because I what it
generates I could write by hand it
really doesn't generate anything that I
couldn't just write by hand but there's
quite a bit of boiler plate one of the
immediate things you can see is what we
get out of this is a nicel looking
repper we also get out of
this a automatic
initializer and this initializer might
even have some default
values so there we go let's do this and
we get the ability to extend this very
easily so if we want to Define what this
thing is in relation to something else
in terms of its equality and we want to
have some custom definition we can
extend this quite easily like this let's
say a a of 1 and 500 and these should be
considered equal to each other and so we
get a lot of these conveniences now you
might want why did they use this
mechanism and why is it that if I take a
look at the three of these helpers they
all look slightly different in terms of
the mechanism that they
use let's do B here in order
to meta program your way to a simple
class so let's say one equals Auto to
here so this is the enum and the name
tupal would look like this equals name
Tuple C with fields X and Y why do they
all look the way they do one of the nice
things about the data class is because
it pushes Behavior onto the Class via
the class
decorator it allows you to preserve your
inheritance hierarchy in other words if
it were the case that you had some
inheritance hierarchy here and that
inheritance hierarchy were important to
you for classifying what these items
were so you could say something like
there's an A and there's a b and you
want to be able to say x is a b object
and you want be able to assert that X's
is instance X of both A and B
then you know that may be some fixed
Behavior you have you want but if you
also want this thing to be a data class
you want to have that
convenience of not having to write all
the boilerplate for the init and the
repper and whatnot you can just kind of
push the behavior with the data classes.
data class and you know what we the way
we might typically write this is like
this I think this is a little bit
misleading these are what are called
variable annotations they were added
fairly late in the game in Python around
python 3.7 or 3.8 you might think oh
this is going to allow me to constrain
this type so it takes only two integers
but no these are maybe my Pi related if
you believe in the pep 484 typ penting
I'm still a little bit skeptical about
the application of Pep 44 typ penting
for you know functions which I write
which often take data frames as inputs
and return data frames and what you
really care about is what the index is
and things like the monotonicity of the
index can't really capture that with pep
44 type penting at least not yet but
here's a simple example of a data class
and you can kind of see how it fits into
a set of different approaches and
different techniques for metaprogramming
to allow you to do something which you
could do anyway but in a much smaller
amount of time very quickly very rapidly
which if you're giving 26 lightning
talks over four hours is what you are
obligated to do now the last thing that
I was asked to look at was eval and exac
and so I'll share with you a little bit
about what those
are uh let's switch over let me restart
my timer
and we'll take a look at eval and exec
so you may be aware that eval is a way
that you can take some code that's in a
string and execute it and get the result
and you may be aware that exec is
basically the same thing but instead of
taking an exact instead of taking an
expression you can take you know any
sequence of statements now one of the
things that this shows us is and this
gives you a corresponding name space so
I can pull that out of the
namespace no I have to give it the
namespace that's right these used to be
uh keywords these used to be statements
in Python 2 so here let's do namespace
and we'll use our walrus Operator just
so that we don't have to do that
separately there we go so you can see I
can you know have any sequence any Suite
of statements and I can execute them and
I can pull this pull this out well when
people look at that they often kind of
get a little bit scared because they say
oh my goodness eval this seems very
dangerous it seems very insecure and one
of the things that I think is important
to understand when you think about exec
and Eva is that they really tie very
closely to how python itself works if
you think about how a module is imported
your import statement you know or your
import function here really just kind of
does something like finds that module on
you know in file so does something as
simple as let say we have a
module from path lib import path we'll
say you know path
mod with suffix py you know your import
more or less looks like this with open
file name as F you know eval or actually
exec f read in some
namespace and then the namespace that
this returns or the namespace is
generated this is just c. modules of uh
the module equals that namespace so
that's really all your import statement
really does and so if you think about it
eval is not really any more dangerous
than importing some code there are code
signing mechanisms where eval will be
significantly distinct from something
like just importing a module but these
are fairly rarely seen in practice and
so for almost all of the deployed use
case of python eving something is not
really any distinct from importing a
module in fact Ealing something is not
really distinct from doing something
like this with
open you know mod.
py as F and then just doing f.
write you know some text you know print
hello you know this is basically the
same thing as eval and you can think
that the mechanism which ended up
writing this code maybe you have control
over maybe you don't so import mod there
we go and so these are just one of many
different metaprogramming mechanisms I
gave a talk a while back about all these
meta programming mechanisms perhaps in a
future lightning talk I can show you how
they compare to each other and why you
might choose one of the other or even
why it is that you might want to use
metaprogram at all but as I said
historically The Collection that name
Tuple was an eval mechanism in fact in
Python 2 if you happen to have Python
2.7 still somewhere you can see that you
can still see the remnants of it
because your name Tuple has an extra
argument called for Bose that allows you
to see the code that it would evil okay
I think that
was five lightning talks I'm not sure
I've lost track of where I am and who I
am uh I think I just gave a couple of
lightning talks I can't quite remember
what they are all about Lauren how did I
do that's uh that was a whirlwind I'll
tell you what and
and that
was much harder than I expected it to be
was it no it wasn't as
quite I don't I don't know yeah yeah
brush it off I don't I don't see you
sweating there yet hi
Jane
hi so I would like to introduce everyone
to my co-host for the afternoon this is
Jane Harman Jane would you like to say a
few
words sure yeah um well I'm excited to
be here um I know I guess everybody on
the call so far um through num Focus
things which I first got involved with
through the Julia Community um and these
days I work at Lawrence Livermore
National Lab as an HPC technical
consultant fantastic I'm so glad that
you can join us um and you can help me
with uh announcing our our trivia and uh
question person who won the who who won
the last trivia round so the question
was um why is python called Python and
do you know the
answer uh Guido is a snake guy that's
that's the answer he's like really he's
like one of those guys who's really big
into snakes you all know somebody like
that in your
life yeah I don't I don't have a precise
answer I thought it had something to do
with Monty Python but I yeah that's
absolutely correct the namesake is Monty
Python's Flying Circus and uh the person
who uh responded on Twitter our winner
for this round is lit seeker ltor seeker
so congratulations
lit um I also wanted to give us a quick
donation update so it looks like we are
now at
$630 raised out of our 750 First stretch
goal if we meet this $
75050 stretch goal what do we get uh
James will submit a poll request to add
a color map to map plot lib with all of
the names of donors during the ton so
help us meet that goal again we've heard
from the maintainers of matplot live
that there are no promises on whether
something will actually be merged
in and I think saw in the chat a mention
of the next goal after that someone was
asking about uh
James's Vim configuration that's correct
people are always asking James about his
Vim RC aren't aren't they
James yes and I hate telling them about
it but you will reveal it if we raise at
least a thousand dollar
today I'm sorry I switched over to my
casual view so you can see what's going
on behind the scenes
and I'm wondering James if you end up
having to reveal your Vim uh settings
are you going to have to create new
settings for yourself so you still have
something that's a little I don't know
edgier or
proprietary yes my goal in life is to
have the edgiest Vim RC among anybody um
no I think the thing about the vmrc is
it's like uh it's nothing special my
vmrc is very very standard uh and so I'm
just like why does anybody care that
much Jane will you be doing any Julia
live coding for
us that is not at all my intention
no the next one live
TV I know you're always supposed to say
yes when you get ask things ask things
live
but I didn't I I don't I don't have your
style
James I uh I see that how much more time
do I have in this break no no no it's
fine uh I see that Tom Caswell actually
uh commented that you don't want to
reveal your Vim RC because it's actually
emac is that
true let me tell you a story and I'll
see if I can make this on brand um I
think the case between vim and emx was
you know whenever you're in school you
learned one of them and you just use
that for the rest of your life and you
kind of got stuck some people switch
over but this is distinct from the tools
which num Focus supports the tools in
Python the tools in Julia the tools in R
which I think are tools which people
actually come to by deliberate choice
they say the tools that I have that I'm
using like uh some of these proprietary
tools I don't want to name any are just
insufficient to be able to do the work
they're not sufficiently open uh I don't
feel like my relationship with the
vendor is a good relationship and so
unlike being locked into Vim or emac as
many of us are when you learn one of
them in school you know the tools in the
pie dat stat the tools in the Julia
stack the tools in the r stack is
something that somebody actually chooses
to use and this is why num focus is such
an important organization and supporting
them focus is so important because this
is this is something that we have all
identified really genuinely benefit Our
Lives benefit our work maybe even
benefit the
world I agree it's actually something
really special um I could talk about
this all day but we actually need to
hear from our next special guest we've
had a couple of uh uh we we've got a
number of people lined up to hear from
this afternoon I think it's really
exciting our very first one uh we will
hear from uh Stefan vanderwal and he is
a researcher at the Berkeley Institute
for data science he is also the founder
of sikit image um Elaine take it
away hello everyone uh it's such a
pleasure to be with you today and uh
yeah very excited primarily about
watching James suffer in front of the
camera oh did I say that out loud uh no
I'm I'm very glad that we're here having
this opportunity to talk about the tools
we're building and about supporting
those tools when I was a young student
in South Africa I had the opportunity to
work on napai for a summer someone
managed to get hold of some funding and
that funding was spent in hiring a
student to document the project the idea
was to document both numai and CPI and
outrageously big task for one student
over a summer but hey it excited me
greatly I took the opportunity with Glee
and 15 years later I'm still here uh
working working on those projects I
think what we saw back there is that you
know we brought the whole Community
together we built infrastructure that
allowed everyone to collaborate on
documenting those projects but a small
amount of money was able to encourage
people to participate in that project
and to build the infrastructure
necessary and that is exactly what
focuses small developer grants program
is for it's to take small amounts of
money allocated to projects for building
infrastructure documentation doing
refactoring the kinds of things that can
make a big difference in a project that
has very few resources of course non
Focus supports more broadly than that we
provide the infrastructure legal and
financial to support projects um in
bringing in their own money and uh
applying for Grants and so forth so that
they can become uh syst stainable
ultimately uh but also we just try and
keep the ecosystem healthy by making
sure that attention is given where it is
needed so thank you so much for your
interested in in interest in supporting
these projects they really need it they
benefit from it and uh yeah your help is
is truly appreciated and we are so
excited about building the next
generation of these tools and making
them available to everyone to use so
thanks very
much
and that's why I don't really use Python
anymore for any of my work I don't think
Python's a very good like oh crap we're
on air again uh
[Laughter]
oh um thanks so much for sharing those
words uh Stefan um our very next guest
that we uh would like to share a
pre-recorded message of support from is
uh Wolf Gang K korf and uh maybe Jane
you would like to say a few words about
Wolf Gang you and him had a uh a keynote
earlier this year together right well it
was really his keynote and uh James and
I were interviewing him but then uh it
became more interactive as as the the
firesight chat went on um and that was a
really fun opportunity we had some good
conversations and uh I got to learn a
little bit about his interests and work
and ways that he's you know helping to
support people entering into science and
and all of that so I'm looking forward
to hearing from him again
now fantastic ftic let's take it away
Wolf Gang
wangis spor project lot of focus so
that's a there's some light one of the
things that 2020 has shown me is that as
humans we started off in small little
groups then started to make bigger
groups like cities and countries but now
we're becoming an interconnected
species and this interconnection is done
through technology technology Bridges
the Gap Bridges the large geographical
gaps and one of the things that most
people don't know is that this
technology is often based on open source
software what is open source software it
is a new very intriguing way of
collaboration one of the things that
happens is people realize that we're
missing certain software Frameworks to
encode video to edit audio and they come
together through the internet find
people from all around the world and
build something and the real miraculous
thing is they do this for free they do
this for free because they want other
people to use these Frameworks and build
new things and build better things for
everyone to share I think this is the
true meaning of equity and if we push on
this we can make sure that every idea is
hurt making the life better for all of
us so what does num Focus do num Focus
helps support the maintenance and
sustains open source projects that are
based on science that means people like
me who make open source projects
available to everyone in the world can
do their work and not have to worry
about supporting their
teams so why is this so important for
research so for me I would like to to
know how stars explode that is my
research and I'm the leader of the
TARDIS Community which looks at how
stars explode and what elements they
spew out into the universe open source
allowed me to connect with people in
Australia and India Russia and many
other countries and bring them together
and work together to make an analysis
package that is not rived by anyone else
that is better than most other packages
specifically because I could get tell
from software engineering to statistics
to computer science uh to astrophysics
and make something unique and N Focus
has supported this effort num Focus
supports many other efforts like these
specifically efforts that help all of us
do research better and for plotting and
for statistics research not only for the
interest of humanity to understand the
stars but interests like covid-19
vaccines interests like climate change
interests that face problems that will
face humanity and will be a problem for
all of us so supporting num Focus means
supporting signs and as we all saw this
year sence saves
lives the vaccines the ambulances the
emergency rooms supported by
science specifically what num Focus does
is support this idea of Open Source
supporting packages that are freely
available to anyone freely available to
anyone in the world that then can do
make their ideas a reality and then can
help and make new cures new methods that
will Aid all of
us so at this point I would really like
to thank num focus and I hope you
contribute to this effort and this is
season's greetings from the TST
collaboration and have a good end of
year hello everyone uh it's such a
pleasure to be with you
today thanks so much Wolf Gang so James
are you ready for your next batch of
lightning
talks um no yes
maybe I guess I've already signed up I'm
already five in we just got to do it
right there's no way but forward there
you go so you want to give me what we're
gonna talk about and uh we'll jump right
into it before we do that I just wanted
to give everyone a quick update on the
donations so we still haven't quite met
that 750 goal yet reminder that if we do
reach that 750 goal that all of the
names of anyone that donates today
through this campaign will be put into a
poll request and that poll request will
go towards map flot lib to commemorate
donors as a color map so you'll be
immortalized for the rest of time in
Matt plot lib
itself which will be around until the
end of time potentially yes uh I I don't
know can they close the poll request
without accepting it
probably so we we shall see but right
I'm curious here if if people well for
people who donate after the pr is
submitted do they get added or do you
have to be in before that pull request
gets submitted good question we have
another three hours left in this
campaign and I think you know when you
miss your opportunity you miss your
opportunity
right for high stakes it's very high
stakes so you're gonna want to hit that
donate Now button make sure you get in
on time so far we've raised
$632 60 which is a fairly specific am
out
um and uh yeah I think we can go right
into
it okay let's uh let's set it up
then all right so our next letter is
f all right how about Funk tools okay
Funk
tools guess functions
generally um if you have any fancy ways
of writing functions James okay fancy
functions for f
yes oh let's stick with the fun tools um
for
G uh maybe get
Adder okay
H um any
ideas something hash
okay I can do hash yeah especially
hashtag cjames sweat is to talk about
this as it's happening what about I
definitely iterators right iterables
iterators yeah what is the difference at
again oh well James this is such an
opportunity for
you
okay I'll look at it that way then and
uh let's do one more so let's do
J can I do a lightning talk on
Jane no okay has to be code related
that's right no proper nouns
okay um let's do Json I don't know if
that counts as a proper noun actually I
feel like a Json is a as a name but
Jason Json if you're French I suppose J
there you
go okay let me share my screen and then
uh go right back into the uh Thunderdome
sounds good before you do that I think
there was one more trivia question that
we want to put out to the audience so
you're going to want to tweet at us
dutc trining use the hashtag cjames
sweat and the trivia question is uh when
was pandas created is that the trivia
question for the next one I think so
when was pandas created let us or first
released uh first released first
released even better because there may
be like a Back to the Future style story
behind pandas that we'll have to get out
of West at a later date my uh family and
I just sat down to rewatch Back to the
Future too and I I would highly
recommend it it's a good good snow day
activity you know what's not a good snow
day
activity what I'm about to do which is
five lightning talks in 25 minutes so
shall we uh proceed let's do it and go
good luck let me share my
screen
okay and let me update my little
subtitle reset my
timer I'll try and fill some air oh I
need to set that back to five minutes
try and fill a little bit of dead air
just so that I
can remember what I'm talking about Funk
tools okay okay so Funk tools is
actually not not too difficult to talk
about so as you know in the python
standard Library there are quite a few
modules that you might interact with
quite a bit especially if you're doing
something that you might call like
functional programming and one of them
is Funk tools and in the funk tools
module I think probably the most common
things that you might interact with are
uh Funk tools wraps or total ordering
and I would say that there's some other
stuff in Funk tools which I'm a little
bit on the fence about I think Funk
tools. partial not actually that useful
I think you just use a Lambda um but I
think wraps is definitely something
that's that's quite useful one of the d
words that Lauren came up with was
decorator let me talk about fun tools.
wrap in the context of a decorator as we
know if we have some code and I'll
continue the timing metaphor that I used
from before so let's say I have some
code and it's in a function and that
function is a slow function and so let's
import sleep from the time module and
let's simulate some slow function and
let's say that I want to time this
function and you can see that one of the
unfortunate things about how I might
time this code is if I were to surround
it with like a start and a stop like I
did before and I didn't want to use that
context manager mechanism because I
didn't want to time a block of code I
wanted to time a specific function I
wanted to put the instrumentation into
the function itself well then I have
this unfortunate result which is that I
have a very messy and very very kind of
uh unfortunately
uh uh intrusive mechanism for timing I
have to put a line of code before and
after I've had a couple of these
different calls you can see I start to
drown in the instrumentation code and I
can't really see uh what the underlying
code was and anytime you see this this
rep repetition of code that's starting
to hide some mechanism your first
intuition might be oh why don't I write
a function and here I could do that what
I do is I write a function that takes a
function as its arguments and so here I
take all of these common blocks of code
pull them
out and I'd write a function here it
takes a function as it's an argument and
evaluates it and so I would transform
these
lines into lines that look like this and
that's still a little bit of intrusive
because I still have to change what the
lines do but you can see at least that
eliminated some of that noisiness from
the instrumentation mechanism but what I
could realize is that in Python
functions actually are rich runtime
objects maybe if I have time in a later
lightning talk I can show you how
functions differ in Python from in a
language like C where they really are
only something that exists to the human
being at the compiler but in Python what
I might say is because py python
functions exist at run time and I can
create python functions at run time what
I'll do is in this thing I'll create a
brand new function and that brand new
function will just forward whatever
arguments are passed to it to the
function that I originally closed over
I'll take that return value I'll return
this and I'll return the inner function
and so if I had my original code with
these three slow functions and I wanted
to instrument them what I could do is I
could create a brand new function like
this
and this thing just takes the original
function passes it through my mechanism
here that creates a new function and
there you go and so I could change each
one of those lines like that and
suddenly I have my instrumentation of
course what I could also do is I could
just rename the original function I
could rebind that original function name
and when you see some code that looks
like this this is actually the decorator
syntax but what happens is when I do
that let's do this I lose my help text
if you look at the help text here the
help text here is referring to the inner
function that I wrote and so one of the
ways that I could get that help text
back is I could re realize that
functions are live runtime objects so I
can do things like set and they're also
mutable so I can do things like set
their
name or set their doc strings
and setting the signature is a little
bit harder but what I might then realize
is every time I write a decorator I'm
doing these common lines and so Funk
tools. wraps is a decorator that you use
within decorators in order to preserve
the help text and the signature of the
functions that you are replacing via
this decorator mechanism the other thing
that's in fun tools which I don't know
if I can do in 30 seconds is total
ordering I told you that I really like
mechanisms that eliminate the boiler
prate from my cold what total ordering
does and this works really well with the
enum type is from collections let's do
this from collections import no from
enum import enum from Funk tools import
total ordering what this does is it
allows you to create a type that assume
that you assume has a total ordering
associated with it it allows you to
create a type and so let's say we have
like a uh I don't know a card
game right and here you have a
two and maybe do a simple card game with
just a couple of cards in
it you can say these cards have a total
ordering that is there's a transitivity
to the ordering it's some other
properties but I don't want to implement
all the different ways to compare them
so what I can do is I can Implement just
equality and less than and total
ordering automatically provides for me
all the other comparison operations for
free so it's another one of these
boilerplate saving
mechanisms
and it is one of these other ways to be
able to jam through code as fast as you
possibly can okay that was Funk tools
let's go over to get Adder oh get Adder
is got a lot going on with it
uh let's
see let me reset my timer and we'll go
into get
Adder okay what we know is that there
are a bunch of different protocols in
Python and
one of the protocols that you have
available to you is a protocol that
looks like the following you have some
class or some object and you want to
retrieve something from that object and
you can write this in a couple of
different ways you can write it like
this or you can use the top LEL function
get
adder and let me show you how this
actually works this protocol I can
probably sketch out a little bit of the
protocol for you let's assume that this
type
initializes this variable X on its
instance so there you go and let's say I
want to build my own mocked version of
get Adder that's going to do the same
thing and I'm going to eliminate a
couple of different considerations here
like slots because I think slots is
often times something that people find
very interesting but I don't think it's
that interesting I think numpy provides
what a lot of people are trying to get
out of slots which is controllability of
their memory uh but let's see if I can
mock out my own version of get Adder
live well here what I'm going to do is
I'm going to first look at the dict for
the object I'm going to look and see
whether this attribute is in the
instance state for this object was
stored in a dictionary unless this
object has slots and if that's the case
I'll return this out of this dictionary
and so here you can see they match up if
the attribute that you're looking for is
found on the class then I have to do
something else well an obvious thing
that I might do is I might say if this
is in the type of the object
dictionary
then return that okay but if this thing
happens to have some base
classes and those base classes happen to
have some
attributes then what you'll see is okay
where do I go next and when you do that
what you will find is that in Python
when they introduced new style classes
which is back in the python two days uh
what they discovered was they wanted to
be able to take the class hierarchy and
linearize it this is called C3
linearization and so any class hierarchy
in
Python must have a consistent linear
ordering associated with it but Diamond
hierarchies are completely fine as long
as you can create a consistent linear
ordering so I'll show you what that
looks like and I think in the time that
I have remaining I can't show you too
many more details of this but it also
introduced
what they call the method resolution
order all python classes can tell you
what the resolution order is and so this
is inconsistent you can see it failed to
create that this is consistent you can
see D can tell you the order in which
it'll look for things so if you look for
an attribute on D it'll go down this mro
D then B then C then a and so to
continue this approach instead of
looking in the types dictionary what I'm
going to do is I'm going to look through
each class in the objects types mro the
runtime types mro and look there so this
is the next step for my get adder and so
this will allow my get Adder to work
with this
Zed there you go now the last piece of
this is what we call the descriptor
protocol if the thing that you found in
this class happens to be something with
a very specific formulation to it namely
it's something with a get
on it and I don't really care what these
arguments are so let's just return
4,000 what you will see is that this get
ater protocol has a couple of additional
hook
points there you go you can see that's
not correct if the thing that you're
going to
return
uh if this thing's
type has a get
method then instead of returning that
thing itself you return the get method
and this is the mechanism by which
things like class method static method
property this is how these are invoked
so I don't no this is self instance
owner so it would be the instance would
be the object and the owner would be the
class so here we go otherwise return RV
so let's
see
and this should be get
here there we go so there you go that's
a little bit of what get Adder does
there's a couple more mechanisms there's
all obviously the get at with
underscores before and after that you
can overload there's get attributes but
here you can see the broad Strokes of
where you find something when you call a
get ater when you do that dotted lookup
where it goes looking for things first
on the instance then on the types if you
ever forget what the mro is I'll tell
you we all learned this in elementary
school you always mow your boat gently
up the ti hierarchy this is how you
figure out which of your base classes
happens to have the attribute that
you're looking for you go up them row
and if the thing that you found happen
to have has a particular method named
get just by convention instead of
returning that thing you return the
result of calling that get method this
is how property class method instance
methods static method this is how they
all work okay that was get ater boy
these uh time flies when you're having
fun huh okay next I'm supposed to look
at hash so let's restart our
timer and let's
go so
hash uh hash is actually kind of
interesting because one of the things
that you might run into is you know we
cash is a little bit misleading a lot of
the times these underscore methods that
you have on your objects are part of a
public vocabulary that you're trying to
you're trying to provide for somebody we
may talk about this later hopefully
we'll get to it but it's often the case
that you want Implement call or you want
to implement Len because you want to
reduce the total surface area of your
API but hash is actually kind of
interesting hash doesn't really mean
what you think it might mean it doesn't
mean oh compute some hash that I can use
somewhere else it more specifically
means compute a hash that I'm going to
use strictly for the purposes of putting
this thing into a collection type namely
a set or a dictionary and hash has a
couple of weird limitations in cpython
for example you cannot have the hash
value B a negative2 sorry negative one
it'll coers it to a negative2 and this
is because Deep In The cpython
Interpreter you know this could be any
other value and'll return this value
exactly but if this happens to be a
negative one it'll cor to a negative2
because this negative one value happens
to be used in The cpython Interpreter as
you know an error value and so what you
can see is the implementation of hash
will actually differ among the different
python implementations this is a design
constraint caused by cpython being
written in C but other python
interpreters are not written in C do not
have this design straight but I want to
show you something else often times it's
the case when people talk about
dictionaries that they say oh the keys
of a dictionary have to be hashable and
that means they must be immutable here
we can't use a list as a keys of a
dictionary because it's a mutable type
and thus it is not hashable and you
might say okay this also applies to the
set which is why in Python we can't have
sets of sets because the set type is
mutable and the set being more or less a
copy and paste of the code of the
dictionary type at least historically
that's how it was first introduced minus
any notion of the values cannot have as
its elements anything that is in
hashable and thus anything that is
mutable and so this is why you have to
have sets of Frozen sets in Python
because this Frozen set is just this
mutable or
immutable set and by the way this still
won't work now when people look at that
they say oh well of course that makes
sense because you can't really hash
something that's mutable but there's a
caveat that they're missing and the
caveat is this you can
hash uh you can compute the hash on a
mutable object but you must compute it
on the identity of the immutable object
and you must you will only be
able to put this
object in a
container that provides intermediated
access so I'll show you a real world
case for this often times when you're
working with the networkx library you
want to have some custom node type so
here what we're going to do is we're
going to create a diph and it's going to
have some custom node type so we'll add
a node We'll add an edge with our custom
node type and for whatever reason this
Digraph object is mutable so why
can't no I'll do a class node why can't
my no type immutable and what I'll want
to do here is I want to compute a hash
on this
thing and if this is a mutable object
what do I return that hash as well if I
return the hash as the content of the
thing bearing in mind that the networkx
diagraph is really just dictionaries of
dictionaries dictionaries I risk losing
this thing in the dictionary because if
I compute this on the state of this node
type then once the state of this node
type changes the hash will change and I
may not be able to find this anymore and
so the way that I'll do this is I'll
compute this on the identity of this
object but this ends up working in
practice because this networkx diagraph
is not something which you have some
disinform access to the content of you
won't be able to say oh look up a new
node with the same underlying State
let's make these you know one one one
and two three four this by the way won't
work uh because these will be three
independently different nodes because
they have different IDs so let's just do
this and I'll show you what you do you
wouldn't be able to do this uh you'll
see that doesn't have that object but
that's actually okay for the networkx
diagraph because most of your
interaction with this thing is going to
look like this it's going to look like
some intermediated access via uh the
some iteration over the contents of this
structure and so in practice every time
I've used networkx and we've we dealt
with the networkx graph as a mutable
type there's been some desire to make
the nodes mutable we have to we have to
Hash them the way you'd hash them is you
hash them on the identity and you make
use of the networkx diagraph
intermediating your access and so what
you would then do is you would
probably then
intermediate or youd probably then wrap
your network X diagraph like this or you
we'll do it with a compositional
mechanism
here and you would then probably
provide here and we do net. G and then
you probably div provide some mechanism
by which to look something up so here
we'll do self G and what we'll do is
we'll store on this structure we'll
intermediate the add Edge and we'll
store on the structure some lookup so we
do self. you know by x equals some
dictionary and then we do something to
add this next node like this we do
something like networks lookup one and
that's how we would get this thing to
work so we basically make the type
intermediate our access and then we can
compute the hash and ident edit it we
don't run into the same problems that we
do this is why this won't work with the
dictionary and the set type because
typically what you're looking for at
least in the dictionary type is you're
looking for dis inated axis you're
looking for that get atter straight into
the type and you're going to lose things
because the IDS won't be the same if you
construct an object with the same value
but it's a distinct object so that's a
little bit about hash I think I'm next
on
to iterators and I think I was asked to
talk about the difference between
iterators and
iterables and
so okay you may have sometimes had say a
list list and you ask that list what is
the next element and that list tells you
I'm not an iterator I can't tell you the
next element you look at that and you
say hold on a second you a why what do
you mean you can't tell me the next
element next element's one but if you
think about this a little bit more
deeply what you might realize is it is
not possible for this list iterator to
tell you what the next element is three
times in a row without remembering what
the last element that it looked at was
and you'd have to think okay where is it
going to remember what the last index
that I looked at was and if you were to
store that information on the list
object itself then if you pass this list
to two separate comp two separate
execution units two threads or two async
tasks or whatever you pass it to they
would interfere with each other because
if they were both looping over this list
then it's going to be the case that
they're going to affect each other's
looping and so that means that you must
externalize the state for where you last
left off and so that's what an iterator
is an iterator is an
externalization of the
state of looping and I think I have to
spell these right externalization of the
state of looping in other words it is a
reference to an iterable and some State
I.E where you left off and so what you
do to get the next element of the list
is you do XI as an iterator for this
thing and then you ask this structure
what's the X element and if we created
two iterators and they were separate
iterators they both maintain that state
separately which means if they were in
two different execution units then
everything would be completely fine
because because they would work
separately from each other but what you
might realize is kind of interesting is
if we have some
computation and that computation
performs you know does three things
let's say We'll compute 10 * 2 we'll
compute 10^ squared and we'll compute 10
plus 2 and actually I'm going to do this
off of something that's passed in
because otherwise it'll do constant
folding on me there we go and then we
return X Y and Z what we have is we
actually have three p pieces of this
code we have three computations within
this larger computation and if it were
the case that we were to put this not
into an eager function but a lazy
generator and we were to yield these
partial outputs rather than return them
all at once and we were to ask this
generator for a generator instance and
go through that generator instance to
get the next portion of the computation
and we have to give this an initial
value so let's give an initial value
like that what we could see is this
generator instance actually gives you
access to its generator frame which
gives you access to its F last ey and
the F last ey you can see
corresponds to the last instruction that
this generator executed in other words I
said 10 yield value 24 yield value 38
yield value in other words an a
generator is an iterable you can iterate
over it in order to trigger a
computation and a generator
instance is an iterator it's just the
underlying computation I.E the reference
to the reference to the iterable which
is a computation that you one
computation you broken down to parts and
some State I.E where you left off I.E
the last
instruction that you
computed that's all an iterator is it's
really just the thing that you canate
over now I have a couple of seconds left
and I'll show you something a little bit
weird there are some places for the this
iterator protocol which I think are
maybe insufficiently defined what
happens if I do this let me create an
iterator on x's and let me go through
the next
value and I told you it's a reference to
this object what if I append another
value to X's what happens what if
insert a value
here what happens let insert a couple
zeros it's a reference and you can see
this iterator is storing the index of
the list that it's going through and so
if you mutate the list object while you
have that iterator object active that
iterator object will will notice that
and will see that because it's not it's
not anything but a reference to this
underlying list and so this can lead to
some kind of strange Behavior because
you might anticipate that once you
create the iterator you're going through
the object itself and this gets to some
Oddities when you're dealing with
iteration over a mutable object because
what happens if for
example I clear out the list here that
should cause the iterator to fail
immediately yep right at this point so
it'll cause the iterator to fail
immediately at that point and so some of
these interactions between an iterator
with a reference to a mutable object and
then mutating the underlying object can
result in some some Oddities in your
code okay so I think that
was that was our I what more do we have
Json okay let's restart our
timer oops Let's uh fix our
screen we'll restart our
timer Json so we all have a sense of
what Json is Json is just some
interchange format where we provide the
contents of this format in something
that looks like an object notation from
JavaScript so we have you know
JavaScript objects or maps and we have
string keys and there's some
restrictions to what you know to how
this must be formatted in comparison to
how what the restrictions on formatting
are for JavaScript itself for example
trailing commas aren't allowed and you
know that's pretty much all there is now
what I want to tell you about Json is
that I'm going to relate this to
something that changed in Python
3.6 uh in Json The Ordering of the nodes
in this particular object or this map
are not part of the standard which means
that this Json
structure and another one
here this Json structure and this Json
structure should be considered
equivalent to each other which is not
which is probably pretty pretty easy for
me to check if I use load s from the
Json module because what will happen is
these will be loaded
into uh python dictionaries and
irrespective of the version of python
that I'm using these will compare as
equal because they have the same value
and the same they have the same keys and
the same corresponding values however if
I were not using Json but XML where the
order of the nodes is in fact part of
the specification or if I had some
script that loaded Json data and then
made a transformation wrote it back to
dis and I wanted a clean diff it may be
the case that if this dictionary type
eliminated that ordering then I might
run into trouble and it is absolutely
the case that prior to python
3.6 python dictionaries were machine
ordered the ordering of that dictionary
depended on wherever those keys were
being hashed the locations that they
were put into and you can see this
Behavior persist on the set type that is
still a machine order type in other
words if I iterate over the elements of
a set in
Python I'll see them come out in an
order that I cannot predict it's not a
random order it is a machine ordering
the machine has decided how to order
them and it does not correspond to the
lexical ordering that I specified when I
write this but I'm telling you it's not
a random ordering and you can see it's
not a random ordering because if I
iterate over it twice in a row it's the
same ordering it's still it's a
deterministic ordering it's just not one
that I can predict and this is always
the case with dictionary Fe over the
dictionary keys values or items they
would always have a corresponding
ordering it's just that you couldn't
predict what that ordering was and to
show you that you can't predict if I
were to insert a bunch of elements in
the set I were to mutate the set in
between then the ordering could
potentially change and so if I do this
from string import asky
lowercase uh words equals from random
import Choice let's create a bunch of
random
words
so we'll create a bunch of random words
of size
10 10,000 should be
enough and if I say for w and words s.
add W and I remove them I should
anticipate seeing the d The Ordering
change this won't be the case with the
modern dictionary you can see the
ordering did in fact change and so
unless you modify that structure for
these machine order types the ordering
is consistent it's just you can't
predict it well prior to Python 3 .6 the
dictionary type was uh one of these
machine order types it would have that
similar Behavior to we to we saw in the
set which is why in the collections
module they had an ordered dictionary
type and the ordered dictionary type in
the collections module was a dictionary
that remembered its machine its uh
insertion ordering if I were to
initialize a dictionary like this in a
version of python prior to 3.6 what I
would see is that because I pass it a
dictionary the ordering was already lost
so what I had to do to make this work is
I'd have to pass this tuples
in a list so that I could ensure that
what I passed in preserved the initial
ordering now in Python 3.6 the split
table optimization was added to
dictionaries and as a consequence of the
split table optimization what we saw was
that python dictionaries now have
insertion ordering and so if we look at
this code and we wonder what is the
difference in Python 3.6 and later and
by bear in mind python 3.6 this was
originally a side effect and python 3.7
this became part of the official
standard but still you know because it
became part of the standard in 3.7 I
don't think you're going to be writing
python code for python 3.6 and you're
say uh oh the dictionaries are ordered
but I can't really rely on that probably
still gonna rely on it the question may
remain what is the difference between
the python dictionary and the ordered
dictionary because it seems like in both
cases we have ordering but and this is
critical and related to our Json case it
is very much the case that with the
python 3.6 and later dictionary the
consideration for equality is based
based only on contents whereas for the
order dictionary the consideration on
equality is based on contents and
ordering thus not if you using Json but
if you using something that had order
dependency or for whatever reason you
were using some Json derivative that
happened to have some kind of ordering
dependency you may still want to use
that order dictionary type because you
may still want to say are these two
documents equivalent in terms of not
only what they contain but they're
underlying ordering that's Json for you
and so let me go back to my list it
looks like oh time flies when you're
doing lightning talks it looks like I'm
all the way through those five lightning
talks didn't even break a sweat I think
we're going to have to up the difficulty
uh I will unshare my screen and let's
see if what Lauren has for us in
store but folks donate to num Focus it's
a good
cause wow great James um that that uh
was a whirlwind how are you feeling
I am about to reach for my performance
enhancing drugs see to see if I can make
it through the remaining on so I think
I'm gonna go get myself some some
coke uh okay kids uh don't do
[Laughter]
drugs want Coca-Cola what's that
including
Coca-Cola um I did want to give a quick
a a fundraiser announcement so we have
reached uh we've raised 84
$80 so we have reached our first stretch
goal of
$750 yay so that means that um all of
the donors today uh including those who
come after um anytime before the end of
the uh this ton anyone who donates today
will be included their name in a PR
request to a color map on map plot lib
no uh no guarant no guarantees that it
will be merg but it will be on a poll
request so you're definitely I think the
colors will be the num Focus colors the
teal and the orange which will give it a
higher percent likelihood of actually
being accepted and here's my Coke don't
worry it's a big one it's a big one
wonderful wonderful I love it um okay
and then also very quickly uh what year
was Panda software first released that
was our trivia question for this round
the answer is uh it was released in 2008
specifically on January 11th 2008 and
our winner from Twitter is
dangu G Swami so um I apologize if I got
your name wrong tweet at me if I got
your name wrong apparently I got the
first Winner's name wrong it wasn't lit
Seeker it's lightseeker so I would like
to make that adjustment
now um and now I guess without further
Ado uh Jane would you like to introduce
our next very special guests for this
segment sure in this segment uh we have
two of num focus's Founders U Fernando
Perez and Travis olant um Fernando Perez
is the Jupiter bdfl uh and Travis is the
creator of both numai and uh and scipi
um and so Fernando would you like to say
a few
words yes uh first of all thank you uh
Jane and Lauren and uh James for all the
work that you've been doing today it's
absolutely wonderful and for those who
have donated participated would really
appreciate it um I wanted to kind of
reflect a little bit on on num focus and
this this is a at this point it has
become what's already kind of a long
history and a really impactful history
um we co-founded num Focus uh Travis and
myself together with Perry Greenfield uh
Jared milman and John Hunter creator of
Matt B li who sadly isn't with us
anymore he was a dear friend to to many
of us um back in in 2012 and I think um
now as I reflect on on the impact num
Focus has had and and uh and sort of the
space it fills um I'm I'm really glad we
did this because
um when I started doing open source work
it was about code right it was IPython I
met Travis I met Eric Jones I met uh
John Hunter and we were completely
focused on the code but gradually we
came really to understand and appreciate
that the code is only one small part of
the story in that as these projects grow
as our idea that we could build an open-
Source stack to do science to do
research to do education to do what we
now call data science we didn't use the
term at the time um other aspects beyond
the code will be the ones that really
dictate success or not that will really
dictate societal impact or not it will
be about first of all the stories that
people will be able to tell with our
code uh many many of our users may not
necessarily contribute directly to the
software where they they use it for
their purposes for their research for
what they teach for the problems they're
trying to understand um and then we will
have to build an ecosystem of
interoperable tools our projects work
together um and they rest on a human
community and num Focus nurtures all of
that right them focus is precisely the
scaffolding and the architecture the
human architecture that makes all of
that possible um and that has first of
all uh been led by amazing people I
think a shout out to not only James but
lean Andy who have sort of shephered the
the organization for years is absolutely
warranted and um and they have really
pushed uh the understanding that this
human community that requires mentorship
that requires uh management that require
that sometimes faces difficult
challenges and we've seen some of those
challenges over over the years um is
actually critical to the success of what
we think of as technical tools and for
those tools to really have the kind of
life-changing impact that they're having
today backstage I was chatting for a
minute with Travis he was asking how are
you doing and I said well I'm a little
tired right now and stressed out because
I just wrapped up a semester where I
taught a course called Data 100 uh which
is called principles and techniques of
data science it's the upper division
course that is mandatory for the
Berkeley uh data science major um but is
also extremely popular campus wide even
for non- Majors I just finished uh with
my uh co- co-instructor and an amazing
team of Tas teaching 1200 students so
this is a course where we teach every
semester about 1,200 1,200 or so
students in the summer another few
hundred we're basically covering roughly
half of the camp the Berkeley
undergraduate population over time goes
through this course which means that at
Berkeley uh if you talk to a random
undergraduate you have probably better
than a 50-50 chance of finding someone
who considers it completely normal to
load their data into a Jupiter notebook
uh import it into pandas visualize it
with matplot lid model it with uh with
panda stats model pyic learn and they
consider that to be their normal work
routine and we have heard from faculty
how life-changing this is because now
they hire undergrads for their Labs um
and the undergraduates actually come in
with really sophisticated chops and data
analysis and using the industry tools
and some of these students are actually
have contributed to to the open source
ecosystem um this was in many ways I
think the dream that we had when when we
were talking 20 years ago um about these
ideas this was sort of the dream that we
could make this possible um and I'm
focus in many ways is actually the the
the in the human infrastructure that
that powers this so I can only thank
everyone who contributes to the projects
to who makes num Focus possible and
those who are helping the organization
today please donate you are truly making
the world a better place uh with with
these tools and so thank you thanks for
having me today um and I look forward to
seeing more of James doing his CRA the
kind of crazy things that he does does
with the Python language thank you
folks thank you Fernando um and now
Travis uh are are you ready to share
with us sure happy to talk I mean I love
num Focus it's such an important
organization uh really grateful that
Fern did a great job explaining some of
the impact it's had um early on I sort
of give a little story about how we
started and I'm focus it was you know
I've been in since I left Academia I did
a lot of coding in Academia I still love
to code I don't get a chance to do it
that often but I still really like the
just the doing of the code but you start
to recognize that there's a real need to
connect uh how do you connect actually
the the incentive structure and the
companies out there there's a lot of
money being made using these tools but
it's not coming back and it's not being
brought into support the ACT creators of
the tools and the maintainers of the
tools that's been a long-standing
problem and one I've been really in
intimately interested in and um I
started as a scientist I still at my
heart you know I I love to geek out of
Science and love to read the latest
papers and i' I'd write more papers if I
had time but i' for the past 13 years
since I left Academia I've been
basically wrapped up in entrepreneurship
trying to figure out how to start
businesses trying to figure out how to
get people how to employ people how to
how does that whole process work as I
was starting to do that I recognized we
need an we need a organization that is a
legal organization that's motivated and
and for the community um every
organization has a culture and has a
concept and it's governed by its board
of directors it's governed by who owns
it and we needed a a community-owned
organization that would represent the
community um as numpy started to grow
where where should the who should own
the copyright of numpy who should own
the copyright of of scipi where should
the IP who who do you talk to if you
want to if you want to uh ask about IP
issues those are real questions around
2011 we were asking like what that's a
good question there was a person who had
grabbed the cop you they have the domain
of nump high.org and they were just
holding it kind of going I don't know
who to give this to do I give this to a
company do I give this to a legal
organization so it really kind of well I
guess we need to start an organization
so so it's work to do that like there's
paperwork to file there's there's people
to to to do a lot of work I was so
grateful we found people who would spend
the time doing that that was a big deal
uh early days and I I reflect on you
know the early conversations and it was
very early and we were didn't know
exactly what we were doing but we we
would meet regularly and we' talk about
how to get it started and uh it was a
lot of fun and then of course the key to
success is getting people engaged and on
board like you know and I've seen this
over and over again with projects and
with communities and with everything you
have to have an energy to get it started
but further you have to have an energy
to involve more people so that we could
you could just in incorporate um more
and more activities so it's really um
it's really been exciting to watch over
the past 10 years how eight years I
guess how it's really grown how num
Focus has gone from this kind of idea
that we've had this idea that we've had
into a bigger bigger deal
um into a bigger deal that is supporting
a lot of people and that's just exciting
it's it's been people like watching
James for example go to every single P
conference that exists trying to figure
out how do we actually pay
administrators right these are things
that have been a really uh a real part
so I just am really grateful Alo
Fernando statements thank you for being
here to to do this if you're out there
wondering if you should donate donate
this is good there's good work going on
a little bit helps every little bit
helps if you can donate in big ways
small ways if your company you're
involved with can make a donation this
is critical work because it it's the
infrastructure work that lets all this
happen so I just I'm happy to support it
we support it however we can I'm
constantly looking for ways to continue
to support and I'm Focus so thanks for
having me and I appreciate being a part
of
it thank you so much Travis and Fernando
really appreciate it I have one very
important question for the both of
you
uh
it's
important Fernando you're on
mute
la
I completely agree this is truly an
International Community
absolutely it absolutely
is um James it looked like you had a
quick
question I was just I was just impressed
hearing Fernando and Travis both speak
about their International experiences
trying to build not just the community
within the United States which has
historically been you know the source of
a lot of computing Innovation but making
sure that this access to opportunity and
access to resources access to open
source software is available worldwide
and so I'm a very very big supporter not
only of num Focus because of its work in
contributing to the projects but also
how it builds communities throughout the
world um I will note that this year we
did our very first Pi data event in East
Asia with pi dat taipe and you can see
there are Piata events coming to every
corner of the
globe great to see I also wanted to hear
Travis here speak a little Spanish so I
was waiting for that to come
to much
[Laughter]
that's awesome well thank you so much
both of you for sharing your experiences
uh you know with num Focus today and
yesterday and to the Future um you know
it's really always nice to hear from
those who were there at the beginning
and and to see that uh you know non
focus is going strong um speaking of
going strong our fundraiser is going
strong I just wanted to give a quick
update on the amount raise that we have
reached our $1,000 goal we are now at a,
oh 75 it just switched right in front of
me um so that does mean games will be
doing a Vim reveal at some time during
the uh during the teleon and that uh our
next goal is uh 1750 so 1,7 $50 that's
our next goal thank you so much and
Travis we will before we let Fernando
and Travis go can we ask them to help us
make a plea to hit that 750 1750 Mark
Travis and Fernando in whatever language
you choose can you help us encourage the
people who are watching at home to
donate so that we can raise
$1,750 for Num Focus for the projects
for not only our communities here in the
US but the international communities
that are behind us in open source
scientific Computing yeah please please
please this makes such a huge difference
open sources is can level the playing
field and help so many people
internationally uh no Focus offers
grants they offer uh development support
mentoring support diversity inclusion
improvements across our our field
there's so much work they're doing
that's really critical that nobody else
will do or can do so please please num
focus is a great place to put your end
of year end of year donations the United
States is tax deductible so there's no
reason not to absolutely and many of you
um in industry benefit from these tools
please give give a little bit back if
you can they are free for everyone they
are free to the world they are free to
those who can less afford them uh but if
you can help support them they are not
free to create people have people need
to put in their time and effort uh and
and we try to do many things to find
those resources but we also need your
help
wow thank you so much take care guys
thanks for stopping
byoo okay um Jane James I think we
better get right back into it and I have
prepared did I prepare I prepared your
next set of letters are you ready
James um no maybe let me switch over and
let's see what we have all
right that was good huh
J do you speak any uh foreign
languages uh a little
I my French is better than my Spanish
but both are not great right now I'm a
bit out of practice but I'm trying to
read Harry Potter in French right now as
a review so there you go that's a great
way to practice
Yeah okay well I'll I'll save you I'm
I'm ready to do with the go with the
coating so yeah yeah exactly spot we'll
save a French Harry Potter for maybe one
of the next stretch goals
um speaking of stretch goals uh if we do
reach our 1750 Mark what do we get uh
after reaching this don't use this code
we'll bring back the Standalone uh pubs
pub quiz Series so if you love pub quiz
at Pi data and you wish that uh you
could attend pub quiz more often to uh
challenge yourself in terms of your
technical prowess and uh uh
abilities yeah you would you're
definitely going to want to join that
Standalone pub quiz but we can only
release it if we meet meet our stretch
goal of 1750 so hold on a second if they
if we hit that stretch goal of 1750
we'll start doing more pub quizzes
and let me remind us that the pub quiz
is where I have the answers ahead of
time so it's really easy for me can we
just do that instead of this instead
nope nope already signed up for this
sorry no way but
forward all right are you ready for K
through
o lay it on me all right so K's got to
be quars star are keyword ARS right
okay uh L for Len
uh okay for Lenn okay M for meta class
okay n for
Nan like like the not a number or like
you know your nan who gives you nice
gifts at Christmas yeah or the nonan
that you eat your food with um that's
another one yeah no uh not a number okay
any type of not not a number numpy not a
number any of them okay and uh oh let's
talk about Big O notation okay yeah
ready for it okay gu let's go right back
into it let's go right back into it when
are we going to do your Vim reveal is
that going to be right after this
segment right we can do that right now
if you'd like whatever you prefer no I
think people are eager to see more
sweating more lightning
hgs okay let's uh let's do it I'll share
my screen and then uh let's see if I can
do five lightning talks on uh keyword
arguments the Len method meta classes uh
Nan which is the same as dump. Nan or uh
or the float Nan is the same dump. Nan
and Big O notation yep
perfect
okay I'm ready whenever you
are so I'll restart my
timer
and we'll go right into keyword
arguments and so let me think of
something that's interesting to talk
about for keyword arguments well as you
already know you know you have a python
function and that function could take
STAR ARS or star star quars this is
additional vartic positional arguments
or keyword arguments in other words this
function can be past any particular
argument spec and one of the things that
always kind of irritated me when people
would write memorizing decorators is
that when they would write a memorizing
decorator like they'd write some
decorator that looks like you know from
Funk tools import lru cache and they do
something like lru cache and this is
some slow function
you know from time import sleep and
we'll make this a really slow function
that adds two numbers together like this
and we'll sleep for one second and then
here what we should see is subsequent
calls to this
thing should if we can get this working
here we go subsequent calls to this
thing should speed up and so you can see
the first few calls the first the first
time we call what particular arguments
it's slow and then it gets faster well
one of the things that always irritated
me here was that they never normalized
for different ways in which the argument
spec could be passed and so what we'll
see here is that those two latter ones
should be fast because look it's the
same arguments I'm just passing them
slightly differently and so what I
thought would be a much better way to
write a decorator might be memorizing
decorator might be to do it something
like this we know that a decorator isn't
necessarily a function that takes a
function and returns a function so much
as any callable that wraps a class or a
de defined function or generator and
returns something and so my favorite uh
implementation of The Decorator looks
something like this what we'll do is
we'll memoize some particular function
we'll store the function somewhere when
you call this thing this is the same
thing as doing the
get uh we'll do a get item actually no
we have to pack this up so when you call
this thing with some arcs and some
keyword arguments we'll actually turn
this into a call that looks like this
and we'll pack the arguments in this way
we'll say the key is a tupal actually
the arcs are already a tupal and a here
we'll turn this into a uh Frozen
set on the on the KW ARS items and we
can do some additional wrapping to avoid
some of the issues that we run into with
mutability uh oh sorry with hash ability
of these things but I think this is a an
an easy start and then what we'll do is
we will say if we do not find this key
here if this is missing
then we'll unpack this thing right back
out so here we get the args and the
keyword arguments we'll unpack that
straight from the key and then we'll
actually invoke the function in order
with these things so here we go and what
we can do is we can put that into a
dictionary here so that should that
should do what we want and we'll return
this this is a return value and then
we'll set this on ourselves so we'll say
set key equals RV and return RV and so
this thing should give us away to me Miz
our function and I kind of like the
dictionary formulation because it really
ties us very closely to this notion of
the dictionary being one way to perform
a lookup table on some function with a
bounded domain now let's see this should
be memoize memoize and we think we have
to return the memoize object here this
thing is a subass of a
dictionary there we go and we have to
pull sleep from the time
module there we go and the one thing
that this also doesn't support is this
keyword arguments problem but what we
could do is we could make use of
inspect of uh rather signature from
inspect and then right here what we
could do is we could normalize these so
we could get the
signature from self. F we could bind it
with these
arguments and then this gives us the
arcs or this gives us the parameters let
me print this out for a second just to
see what that looks like yep and this
gives us pam. args and I think pam. KW
args and this should give us a
normalization got us do a DI here this
should allow us to normalize those
keyword arguments so it's yep arcs and
quars and what you can see is this arcs
and quars nomenclature is actually in
the standard Library itself
this thing and this should be what pams
ARS pam. KW ARs and what we should see
here is a and we should and we should do
this on the lookup actually so we should
do this
here uh and then we'll do this we'll
construct the key yeah we'll construct
the key off
this uh so we'll do this equals pams dot
so this will will give us some
normalization we'll do it on the call
and then down here I think that gives us
what we
want ps. args and pam. KW ARs and then
down here we should just unpack it like
that so they should already be
normalized at this point so hopefully
that works and we got to get this thing
working or we're going to run into
trouble this needs to be forced into a
dictionary there we
go yeah there we go told you I could do
it so here you can see KW ARG
normalizing memorization written in the
form of a decorator that is actually a
class that returns an instance oh I know
I could do that I'm feeling good false
false confidence because this is about
to crash and burn our next thing that
we're going to talk about and let me
update my screen before we get to that
is
len okay what can I tell you about
Len well one of the things that we might
know is that often times when we're
writing a python class uh it is our
desire to make use of a built-in
vocabulary that's provided us to the
Python language as opposed to inventing
that vocabulary ourselves so if we had
some problem that say you know modeled a
card game we had a deck of cards we
don't really want to have some code you
know here's a deck of cards and then you
say you know uh d.n cards you don't
really want to write something like this
because this is just going to lead your
us to say is it numb cards is it is it
you know number of cards what Earth is
and you'd rather just say you know Len
of D this is how you con convey that
this structure which is a deck of some
kind of cards has some notion of its
size but whenever you do that you have
to be very careful to be to pay close
attention to what this protocol actually
means so we'll create this with say a
four of hearts and a three of clubs and
you can see okay Our Deck has two cards
in it now I as I said you have to be
very careful about what what that means
what this particular protocol means I
can in the case of hash if you if you
don't look at it right if you think oh
this represents just some some numeric
value that's computed from the state of
the object that's not quite correct
because hash is much much narrower in
terms of how it's used but Len is
actually a little bit broader and Len is
something that you know anything that
has a notion of a size or anything that
specifically is a
collection
ABC do uh sized you know you'd Implement
lenon and let's just double check I
think this should be Sol because I think
it all requires is a len is
instance
desized but it may also need an in oh no
it's all it needs is a len okay well the
thing with Len is if you have to pay
attention to one or two little caveats
because you could think that if I were
dealing with say a card game example
what I might also have is like a hand
like a hand of Poker flush straight or
whatnot and you might say oh for this
particular hand I want to look up the
probability but the probability is just
a measure and some measure space and so
you might say oh you know what I could
just write a Len and I'm going to be
really clever and I'm going to return
you know the probability it's 50%
probability of this but what you're
going to find is that Len is actually a
little bit more limited than that it has
to return an integer and you might say
you know what I'm gonna model in this
game like a pot and this is the amount
of money or maybe I'll I'll model my
purse this is the amount of money that I
have and this Len you know is an integer
but you know when I play poker I play
for 20s not for one so it's always some
integer value and so but I'm not very
good at poker so you know I have a
negative amount of money and when I
compute the Len here you can see that's
also a problem because a len has to be
not only an integer but greater than
zero and so when you think about these
different protocols you think about the
design that you're trying to to to
create you really have to think a little
bit about what these protocols mean in
terms of the conventions and in terms of
their restrictions in the case of Len
what we see is this represents some
discrete nonzero measure of the object
but there's something something beyond
that if you think about some objects
they may have multiple distinct Notions
of their length like for example a
pandas data frame is a two-dimensional
structure is its length the number of
rows or the total number of cells and
that could be ambiguous and maybe at a
later lightning talk if we have a little
bit of time we can talk about what
actually happens when you have this
ambiguity because it turns out that when
you're modeling a python object with
with these object model methods with
these data model methods what you're
looking to implement is the one unique
privileged notion of that thing and so
if you had a class and you showed it to
me and you said I implemented Len on
this class the first question I would
have for you is is this the size of this
thing as a measure that is non negative
discreet I.E an integer and is this the
one unique privileged notion of what the
size of this thing is because it has two
different Notions of size maybe you
don't want to implement this as a
Le now I want to show you one more more
thing about Len uh you can well I'll
leave it there I would I might have
showed you that you know in the builtin
you can always do something like this
this is this is just too too obvious
right here I'll say
Len this this is uh this used to shock
people but now now I don't think it
shocks
anybody so here you can always uh swap
out what Len does and surprisingly
enough doesn't cause as many problems as
you might
think all right that doesn't cause as
many problems as you might think uh
hopefully too bad we already went
through b because I could have showed
you all the weird things you could do
with built-in
patching uh but here you go you can you
know lenon is just one of the protocols
like any other it has the same
considerations of all as all the other
protocols and you should be careful when
you implement it to really understand
what it means and if somebody happened
to implement Len in a way you didn't
like just go into the built-ins and
patch it out and you're good to go so I
think that takes care of Len the next
item that we wanted to discuss was The
Meta class and I don't know if I could
do meta classes in five minutes but I'll
give it a
try so as we know from python when the
new style objects were added to python
uh new hierarchy was created so they all
descended from object and they all had a
meta class and so in Python 2 it turns
out that there are a couple of different
ways you can create a new style object a
new style object was either an object
that directly inherited from
object whoops or an object that
inherited from something that inherited
from
object
or a object that had a meta class and
you used to be able to do this you used
to be able to put it uh in line and a
meta class was just a
you know a class that just that derived
from type now what the thing actually
meant was sometimes unclear to people
and so you'd get a lot of advice say oh
stay away from meta classes they're
really dangerous they're really
unpleasant they have no purpose they're
just about job security they're just
about making your the lives of your
co-workers harder but I really push back
on this and reject this because when I
look at meta classes in Python I see a
specific pattern that they are there to
solve it's not a pattern that everybody
has but it is a clear unambiguous
pattern and there are only three ways
that I can think of easily to go about
solving this problem and the problem is
if you have a base type and a deriv type
it is possible to create constraints on
the base from the derived so for
example if you had a function
here and here you had a function that
that required that the base type look a
certain way so you're going to return
self. Fu and you wanted to make sure
that somebody doesn't and let's do
this and you wanted to make sure that
somebody doesn't accidentally turn that
off and then you run into trouble what
you could do easily enough is you could
say if has Adder base
Fu you can say raise type
error base is
improperly properly provided so you
could do something like that so if you
have some issue in which you're worried
that a base class might change and you
want to have a constraint on that that's
quite easy and the reason that's quite
easy is at the time when you're
performing this derivation when you're
deriving from this bass already exists
so you can look at it you can touch it
you can ask it questions about itself
and you can say hey do you conform to
the style that I look like but the other
way around is a little bit harder what
you can think is if you control the base
class and you know somebody is going to
write a derived class related to you and
you have some constraint that you want
to enforce not from the derived up to
the base but from the base down to the
derived for example let us
say that
this let's do this is it looks like this
here you want to create an instance of
this derived class and you want to call
Bar on this derived class and you're
worried that the people who are writing
these won't Implement that correctly how
do you do that because at the time in
which you write this Base Class the
drive class doesn't exist yet and so
there are three different approaches and
I have one minute to show the approaches
the first approach is if you take a look
at the no the first approach is uh build
class if you take a look at the
built-ins in the built-ins module there
is a function called build class and
this gives you the ability to
introspect and to to uh hook into every
single class building operation that
occurs in your entire program so let's
see if I can do
this
BC let's see if that should hook there
and I got to say builtins here and here
you can see if I do import Json uh here
we'll pass we'll print out the arcs and
the quars and you can see every single
class definition in the entire program
is now intercepted that is a very very
powerful technique but it is unwieldy
the other way you could do this is via a
meta class and so what you would do is
you'd have Bas Define a meta
class this looks like this and I'll take
just a couple of extra seconds I think I
have just a little bit of a grace period
and you could do a new here this is
class name bases body I'll print out
base
meta with a name and I'll return super
new class name basis and you'll see it
intercepts now the reason why you
wouldn't want to do this is and I don't
know if we have an opportunity to talk
about this in that much greater depth
but the reason you wouldn't want to do
this
is super new oh this is type the reason
you wouldn't want to do this is this is
actually kind of difficult to control
because if this layer also added a meta
class then you have to deal with how do
you combine the meta classes and so the
popular Tech technique these days is not
to use a meta class it is instead to use
a special method at a python 3.6 in its
subass which is a little bit easier to
manage and so this will trigger on every
creation of every subass that derives
from you but fundamentally The Meta
class is useful because it's a way that
you you enforce a constraint or a
guarantee from a base class down to a
drive class where the other way is very
easy going down the type hierarchy is
very tricky so I think I took an extra
30 seconds or so on The Meta class let
us move on to our numpy
dot
Nan or our regular
Nan so it turns out that the numpy Nan
is just a float Nan so if I say from
numpy import Nan this thing is just
float Nan right and it's not just equal
to actually it won't be equal to it'll
actually be the float Nan because what
I'm going to show you that's kind of
interesting about this Nan type oh no it
is isn't it what i np. n is it a
different instance of the
Nan aren't you float Nan yeah you should
be oh I guess because it's
a yeah no it's not yeah it's not because
this is not a Singleton object so it
really is just somebody who they just uh
implemented float Nan but uh what's
interesting about Nan is the following
Nan is one of these objects that is not
reflexively equal to itself so if I say
x equals float Nan it is definitely the
case that X is X
but it is not the case that X is equal
to X because it turns out that Nan is an
object that looks kind of like this it
has an EQ and that EQ just returns false
because it's not a number it's not equal
to anything it's not even equal to
itself which is why in my first case I
could say oh is num. n equal to float n
no it's not equal to anything and in
this case it's not actually the float n
because they're just two different
instances of this of this object it's
not being interned because there really
isn't any built-in interning of The
cpython Interpreter for anything but
integers or strings now one interesting
thing about this is if I happen to have
a nan value and I'll just use nump high.
Nan it is not the case that this Nan
value is equal to itself even though
it's the same underlying object but if
this is a list of Nan values it is equal
to itself because if you take a look or
even a tupal of Nan values I think even
a set of Nan values they should all be
the same yeah any sort of python level
container of nand values now when we
talked about the nump in Dray what I
told you was that it was a mathematical
type that was aware of its contents what
I think is quite interesting is if this
is not a python collection a tupal a
list a set of Nan objects but a numpy
andd array of nans we see different
Behavior altogether if this is an array
of nans this is not equal to itself in
other words when python collections
compare for equality what they do is
especially the order collections they
look for the first object that is not
the same underlying object and then
compare for equality on that so even
though the Nan is not reflexively equal
to itself a list of Nan objects are
equal to each other because they have
the same contained objects when we
talked about the python list versus the
numpy and Dray one of the things we said
was a distinction between structure-wise
operations and elementwise operations
but we can see something very similar
occurring here a python list of Nan
values is compared to another list of n
values in a structure-wise way not
really knowing what the contents are but
just saying oh you're a bunch of Nan
values okay you're all Nan values you're
all the same underlying objects you're
equal but a numpy and Dray implicitly
always broadcasts some operation so if
you ask two nump and drays are you equal
to each other it's going to broadcast
that operation on all the on all the
content it's going to do that element
wise and it's G to ask each Nan are you
equal to this Nan and Nan not being
equal to anything even itself is gonna
say no this also ties us to an error
that we almost certainly have seen many
many times before if I have a python
list and I want to say is this list
empty or not I might say if X's but if I
have a numpy and Dr array and I want to
ask if it's empty or not I'm going to
see an error and the error I'm going to
see is that the truth value of an array
with more than one element is ambiguous
use any or
all and the reason for that is even this
truthiness operation in numpy is
broadcast has this kind of notion of
being being able to see the contents of
the structure so it's being broadcast to
all the elements so what this will give
me is it'll give me some structure which
has maybe some True Values and some
false values and I have to do any or all
now there's only two common places that
you'll run into where if you have a
collection type or at least off the top
of my head where you have a collection
type that's either uh built-in type or
in the standard library or in a popular
third party module where if you ask this
type if it's empty or full and you won't
do it with this pep 8 supported syntax
you actually have to use something
special like all the other would be
multiprocessing doq which by virtue of
being potentially in an inconsistent
State because it has this concurrency uh
mechanism within it you know you
actually have to ask are you empty
otherwise you can see there's actually
somewhat an asymmetry here now I
actually don't mind this asymmetry
because when I think about this a python
collection type is fundamentally
different than an umpy and Dray a python
collection type just represents some
program structuring it represents some
way that I'm setting up a set of
computations that I'm going to perform
whereas a nump and represents a
computation itself and I don't really
want to mix and match these in fact I
want to use these in combination
symbiotically with each other I want to
have these python lists these python
sets these python dictionaries
representing the underlying structuring
of the computation I'm going to perform
each experiment I Loop to the
experiments and I run the experiment and
the nump and representing the underlying
computational type the experiment itself
and so it's okay for me to see this
asymmetry between determining if this
thing is empty or not and it's okay for
me to see this asymmetry in determining
whether these things are equal if they
happen to contain Nan values so I think
that's numpy
n last on our list we have Big O and I
suspect this is not the television show
but
the uh asmic
complexity so uh we can actually see
consequences of Big O quite easily in
Python I've talked about some of the
Python built-in types and I mentioned
the python set and let's construct a
very large python set and so let me
actually do this import perf counter
and I'll import sleep from Context lib
import context manager
I'll I'll create my timed again uh let's
do this let's start up our perf
counter we'll stop
it we'll go finally we'll yield here and
then we'll print out the
message and we'll align it a little bit
and we'll say what is it Greek capital
letter delta T and we'll say stop minus
start2 F seconds there we go so here's
my simple timed mechanism and I should
be able to see uh some Notions of bigo
on even the basic python collection
types for example if I create a set with
a Rand with a large number of random
integers let me do this with the list
first uh let's do random
range because I like Rand range better
actually I'll do Rand in because it'll
tie out to what I want to no that I'll
do Rand
range I L I lost precious seconds there
deciding whether I want a Rand range or
Rand int I can't I can't keep going on
like this I got to be more focused there
we
go let's do this with 10 elements and
let me let me see if an element is in
here and just to make this timing you
know and this is the python list but
just to make this timing fairly
consistent I'll look for an element that
I know doesn't exist and so here I'll
increase this to 100 elements and what
I'll do is I'll do list there I'll do
I'll do some program structuring here so
we'll do from numpy import log space
I'll do a log space up to
six so this is the
size so there we go so I'm going to do a
log space like that so here I get a
logarithmic space and I'll do this with
uh what is this five samples there we go
and so here you can see I'm going to do
this with increasing sizes and I'll
round
these let's see let's do this from zero
to five maybe so I'll do this from one
element 10 elements is there we go and I
think if I do that there we go that's
what I wanted and I'll do the
following for the sake of time we'll
increase the size of this thing
and we'll print out the size and we'll
see how this thing behaves as this thing
grows and we'll check if 2000 is in this
structure with our time structure we do
stop minus
start and I think we have
to okay that's good and
then why doesn't that show me the timing
that I
want
so this should show times let me double
check I have perf start and start what a
message that's
interesting uh let's make
this maybe I have to make this larger
maybe I can't see that timing so what we
should see is we should see the
complexity of this corresponding to the
size of this structure and so just have
to double check and see why it is let's
do something really quickly uh with
timed let's make sure my timer Works yep
that timer works so what we should see
is we should see the timing of this
structure uh increase as we go let's do
this and it may just be that we don't
have enough Fidelity in this measurement
this may be too small so let's just make
this a little bit bigger
yeah there we go it's just that thing's
too small and so we're going to have to
make this way bigger to see these
timings or you know what we can do we
can give it more decimal points here so
we'll see yeah there we go you can see
as we increase the size of this by 10
the thing gets slower and slower by 10
elements but we switch this over to
being a set you can see the timing is
consistent and so you can see very
clearly in built-in python structures
this constant time for this is linear
time distinction because if this is a
python list it may be a little bit
tricky because at least the computer
that I'm running on is fast enough that
I can't see this so you know what I'll
use per counter NS and I'll show you
this answer in
nanoseconds and that should give you a
very clear view of this bigo you can
see there we go and you can see linearly
the timing increasing as we go whereas
if I change this to I python set which
is a machine order type you can see that
timing is constant so there you go it's
a little hand Hands-On demonstration of
a basic notion in in ASM totic
complexity that the time of finding
something in a human order structure is
dependent on the time the size of the
structure it's a linear order linear
relationship whereas a time of finding
something in a machine ordered structure
like a python set is constant or at
least amortized constant but in this
case since we're not modifying this
thing that amortization cost is not
really considered so there you go big
old notation and I think I am done with
my batch of five lightning talk
how did I do Lauren I think that was
great James but there's still many more
to come what do you have another 11 so
you're about halfway through a little
more than halfway through the alphabet
only oh jeez how you feeling you're
generous I was gonna I thought this was
a good time to tell him he was doing
just
[Laughter]
okay I like the uh the alphabet tie in
there amazing well let's also check in
on how the fundraiser is going I think
we're doing okay over there too uh we're
at uh
$1,000
$1,085 and so we are still trying to
meet our stretch goal of
1750 so donate donate if you uh like
what you see if you don't like what you
see you can also put that in the
comments when you donate even small
amounts count uh it'll show your name
right up along the bar it says the most
recent donors so you're definitely going
to want to uh check that out so um Jane
I think we have some special guests that
are logging on we do uh first up we're
going to hear from Katrina reel uh who
is on the board of directors for Num
focus and in particular serves as the
num Focus Treasurer um and after Katrina
speaks uh we'll hear from Jeff reeback H
who is one of the core devs for pandas
so Katrina H
welcome hi Jane thanks so much for
having me um really really excited to be
here um as you mentioned um I'm a board
member on num Focus I'm also the
director of data science over at Cloud
flare you can see our wall of entropy
behind me um our team is uh primarily
python based um didn't want to mention
I've been using python for 22 years now
I actually was counting this up recently
and so 22 years of python and uh doing
everything from you know a former
developer open source advocacy uh
Community um relations all of those
things like that very very excited to
represent this Community um and do
everything I can in order to make it
successful and a healthy vibrant place
for open source um and open science um
and I did want to mention actually a
couple of things um we had talked a
little bit about why open source is
important and why open science is
important and I think that you know not
only do we want to support the
developers that are a part of this but
we also want to open the conversation
with a larger scientific Community which
is where I kind of came in more on the
scientific side and so um being able to
use these tools and have this no barrier
to entry way to get into the sciences
and have powerful tools that are um
adopted and supported in order to be
able to produce you know repeatable
science and open science I think is
incredibly important to us just as a
community and also as a society um and I
do want to mention that you know not
only are these tools being used you know
for covid-19 research um you know I can
say at least from the Cloud Player
perspective you know these tools are
also being used for you know solar wind
taxs um you know investigations and
things like that they're um all over the
place and seeing the power of how these
tools are able to affect all of us
around us I think is an important thing
for us to do I also want to take a
moment to also talk a little bit about
the num Focus Pi initiatives that our
our education initiatives I think are
incredibly important to part of the
things that num Focus does and um open
source in particular I think is
something that people Overlook as an
educational tool and somebody like me
being a old precocious graduate student
who came in uh wanting to learn how to
code learning how to understand
computers learning how to understand
scientific Computing open source was my
Gateway into that and it opened more
doors than I care to um acknowledge at
this point being able to read people's
code being able to be coached by some of
the best developers I've had the
privilege of working with and um being
able to be a part of that and share that
knowledge with others I think is
something that is really important and
another reason to really give generously
to numb Focus um in order to support the
Piata community and make that a healthy
Community where we can give back so with
that I'll go ahead and um turn it over
to
Jeff thank you Katrina it was great
hearing from you and uh and now Jeff
would you like to
share yes hello so I'm uh Jeffrey Beck
I'm U I represent the pandas project um
I um I personally I work at uh two Sigma
Investments and and we're of course uh
you know large pandis users um uh as
well as we consume you know large parts
of the open source ecosystem and of
course we give back uh you know as much
as we can really to uh the ecosystem um
I've been involved with uh you know
pandas and uh for over 10 years um and
actually within num Focus we've been
involved for at least five or six years
uh you know attending many events um
I've uh done um you know reviews for
many events and I think that you know
something Katrina touched on was that uh
the ability to have these events you
know in in person excluding this year of
course uh makes for an amazing
experience um for people to not not only
network but to really learn and
understand how open source Works how to
get back um you know in particular the
panis project we actually really try to
be welcoming to newcomers um we have you
know a ton of contributors who you know
some are driveby of course but we really
like to have uh you know repeat
contributors and and things like that
and you know as far Asus goes they have
back stopped us you know from the very
beginning um you know we have recently
actually only recently begun to receive
some funding opportunities um from
external uh folks um you know be a TI
lift or uh we have some several czi
grants and you know num Focus has been
there all the way and so I am like
really like honored to to be a part of
this of this ecosystem I mean part of
the reason I think this uh ecosystem
really works is the fact that we have
you know quite a number of you know
projects that really are vibrant and
really are um interconnected and in fact
that's the reason to support num Focus
because we want to cont contribute or
continue this vibrancy we want to make
the projects better and interop better I
mean the worst the worst case scenario
is like you know a project is just not
advancing and then you know new python
conversions come out and it's just not
working but I think with the support of
everyone and the continued support of
num Focus we can really uh you know keep
these products going these are all
thoroughly mature prodject uh products
and you know at this point you know we
definitely want to we have bugs and you
we have fixes but at the same time we do
want to um you know fix any
long-standing things that are going on
especially um you know to make the
projects interupt
better Jeff I have a question for
so the pandas project has been the
recipient of some money from czi and for
the folks watching at home who are
deciding whether or not they want to
donate uh could you tell them a little
bit about where the Dona money goes to
can you talk about the small development
grants that pandas has received or where
some of the development money from CI
has
gone these are great questions James um
so we received several different funds
so uh one for example we received
several grants to improve our
documentation I think documentation is
probably one of my my uh most important
things I push in in any uh uh any PRS
that come I mean just being able to find
things extremely important um we've also
begun a large amount of effort to
improve uh we'll call it uh what we call
extension array in pandas and this is
you know a big effort to really make
things you know decouple a little bit
from numpy and the reason for that is to
you know allow high performance to allow
uh you know effective interop you know
when pandas was developed you know over
10 years ago the world was a very
different place and so we're trying to
modernize pandas without um having to
resort to like a a version two or a
version three we are really trying to uh
you know make the car better in place
and I think we you know so far we've
been fairly successful at doing that and
we'll continue to do that um this
requires funds we requires you know
dedicated um uh time from folks um I
happen to be have a full-time job and
but at the same time I can use you know
time you know after my job to do it but
not everyone can and so we're trying to
really um have folks who can work on
pandas more and more without sacrificing
uh the regular lifestyle hold on a
second Jeff I think what you just said
was if people watching at home give five
do or $10 it could make the Panda's
documentation better I think that's
worth five bucks just just between you
and
me well you know it could of course make
the documentation better I mean I it's
it's absolutely true though every little
bit helps um you know we've had people
from all over the world who are able to
contribute just a little dock string
improve one single function put an
example in there I you know it's funny
earlier uh this was actually last year
we ran a worldwide Sprint um and we had
contributions from over 30 countries
over a 24-hour period it was just pretty
pretty amazing that these little things
can happen and and it could be anybody
can do this that's the the cool thing
about this we can really have lck all
these little contributions uh they just
add up and that's the same is with
donations they just add up a little bit
here and there is really
helpful thank you Jeff and then I've got
a question for Katrina um if you're
still around Katrina I yeah I'm I'm
wondering if being on the num Focus
board has given you maybe insight into
the ways that num Focus operates and and
makes use of the donations um and
incoming grants that that we get so
actually I think it's really interesting
to see how things run over on the numb
Focus side and especially um acting as
treasure has been really interesting to
me to see how we service our projects um
I just want to mention that I mean the
overhead that num Focus takes is
incredibly low right I mean compared to
the amount of services that we're trying
to provide for the community and the
amount of support that we're trying to
give to the community so um money that
goes into nub Focus really is the intent
is for it to go back into the projects
um there's a great great
um responsibility there that um you know
everyone wants to give as much as they
possibly can for the betterment of these
projects in order to provide as much
stability as we can to these projects
right um so I think it's been kind of
fascinating especially as a board member
to feel like you know we're seeing where
the money is going we're seeing how
people are using it we're seeing the
community coming together we're seeing
people getting better at how to write
grants and teaching each other how to be
able to get money to fund their open
source projects and make them more
stable and be able to fund full-time for
developers like Jeff was just talking
about um it's it's actually been really
really rewarding experience
yeah aome thank you Katrina and Jeff are
you going to stick around for James's
Vim reveal oh you bet yes I I I wouldn't
miss it I you know I've been uh I'm not
personally a VI user I use emx but I'll
still you know get a few tips there's
there's nothing interesting in there no
but I think we should do
it was one of our stretch goals and I
think we should do that now before we
launch into the next set of letters what
do you think I think he needs to give it
up I'll see if I can bring it up on the
screen uh I think I just lost my vimrc
um but before I bring that up and I
reveal this very personal thing to the
world if I could ask Lauren could you
help share with everybody what our
upcoming goal what our upcoming stretch
goals are what they might get if they
donate we really want folks that donate
we know these tool these tools and these
projects are very helpful for you it
really helps the projects even small
amounts especially small amounts from
Individual donors it really means a lot
to the projects it helps fill up the
small development Grant uh rounds we do
Katrina multiple small development
grounds each year and how many projects
per round do we tend to approve grants
for about 10 say it's about 10 projects
per round and um I mean we really do our
best to fund as much as possible during
those small development Grant rounds for
sure uh and I think we've we've done
these for almost all of the projects
these are documentation improvements
these are website improvements these are
community events they're all sorts of
things that directly impact the users
and so we really want uh if you have the
ability for you to donate if you don't
have the ability to donate we'd love if
you could volunteer as Jeff said help us
out with the documentation come to a p
dat event but this is a community
sponsored effort this is an effort that
is grown that grows stronger as we get
support from you out there in the
community did that did that buy enough
time that I I don't have to do my Vim on
reveal I don't know where were you were
you opening up your your Vim
or hold on I okay let's see there's
really nothing interesting in here okay
that's okay while you're doing that I
actually um I've got a couple of trivia
questions to announce so we didn't read
the last one on air it was the Twitter
one only that uh it was a throwback to
the letter B in which python version was
the built-in breakpoint function
added does anyone know
here so the answer is 3.7 and our winner
on Twitter was uh Jurgen gach so thank
you
Jurgen and I have a new question for all
of you that's going out on Twitter right
now so um let's see num Focus supports
more than just python initiatives so
here's a question about Julia Lang what
year was the Julia project first funded
by num
Focus your answer will be after the next
set of questions and so uh go ahead and
answer us with uh
dutc training use the hashtag cjames
sweat and get us that answered and uh we
will announce the first person to get us
that answer correctly on Twitter after
this next set of questions uh next set
of lightning talks
okay I guess I have to uh share my
screen again and show you I think you
better he is for procrastination it
seems and S
isass let's see picture and picture here
you can see my jam I have a question for
you uh nothing too fancy I use pathogen
because I haven't bothered to upgrade to
any of the newer ones wait you have a
question I think there may be some curse
words in here so I'll scoll really
quickly cursor would be around uh Stupid
plugin won't set my tab settings
correctly why does it keep inserting
this or that I know I've I've messed
with that a couple of times oh look at
my uh undo Rel levels I'm like boy I
really need to have 10,000 levels of
undo because you know that mistake I
made 15 years ago is important in fact I
even have a plugin for that called gundo
that allows me to view the graph of all
of I updated this three hours ago yeah I
tried to make my markdown files python
files so you can see I haven't updated
this in a while uh then what else oh
there we go let's
uh let's view our vmrc again okay let's
see where we were and then what else do
I have in here that's interesting uh
line numbers this is what turns on line
numbers on and off but when I do these
kind of presentations I try to hide
everything there's a plugin here called
Goyo that hides all of the extra
mechanisms is really supposed to be for
people who are writing you know text or
blog posts there's also a plug in I use
called Limelight that just highlights
the current paragraph I'm under uh you
can see I have these are my guno
preferences uh oh I like to move logical
lines not physical lines uh I really
hated the capital K I don't care about X
mode apparently I don't even remember
what x mode is all about uh let's see
what else is in here I don't even know
what this is from so I just better
remove this boy this is like clean up my
vimrc instead of revealing it uh
anything else really tired of oh I'm
glad I didn't put a bad word here but I
was really really tired of dealing with
the indent settings and so I found
somewhere some random combination of
these and apparently this didn't work
for JavaScript code that I was working
on um beyond that I also have a little
bit of custom python code which is how
that auto Runner works it actually pulls
some block of code from a markon file
into a text file and then I use I notify
to run that and then you can see I can
run code in Python 2.7 in Python uh I
can also have some other one of these
that I don't really use anymore for
running this in Python 3.9 before I had
python 3.9 on this machine and beyond
that see there's nothing really too
fancy a couple of you know couple of
different leader commands to turn on
whites space I don't even remember what
these are I just uh I just yeah I just I
guess mus muscle memory at this point uh
and then a couple of file settings uh to
set specific file types nothing private
yet and then some linter
settings uh I guess I was really
interested in using one of these lint
one of these uh code uh like linters at
one point and then wow I'm really
definitely above this is so old we're
definitely above version seven of uh of
vim and then a bunch of other settings I
haven't seen in a long time boy this is
fascinating I set the encryption method
to lowfish 2 O that's really important
because I definitely open and close
encrypted files in Vim all the time no
idea where this came from uh oh that SQL
type default definitely don't give me
syntax highlighting for my SQL not on
this computer uh and then here's a bunch
of these settings for the Goyo plugin
and I think I'm close to the end uh oh
Ms build files for the time where I was
dealing
with I was building python on Windows
and I was using Vim to edit the Ms build
files and that's it that's it absolutely
fascinating isn't it my Vim RC
everybody so James I don't know it was a
little bit
blurry did everyone uh get that a little
bit fast
too it was pretty blurry on my end too I
think uh maybe that was part of his
secret plan to maintain I think it was
intentional I completely agree I'm a
little underwhelmed
James I guess if we if we hit 1750 uh
I'll post my vmrc on Twitter oh thank
you okay you heard it here uh folks uh
if uh
James if we if we reach our next stretch
goal of 1750 James will post his Vim RC
on Twitter so you don't have to scroll
back back through the YouTube live and
see it real fast real
[Laughter]
blurry that's how Vim RC's are they're
they're as somebody on Twitter said it's
they tend to be dustier than your
basement that's just the nature of it I
I challenge Jeff to show us his whatever
emac uses to config itself I'm sure it's
all written in eisp I'm I'm sure it's no
better than what I had
here my emex is boring
so super
Bor okay well uh this this was an
interesting segment thank you so much
for uh joining us uh Jeff and Katrina um
really fantastic to have you here and
thank you for helping us make this event
a success yeah thanks so much for having
us thank you so much Jeff Katrina any
final words to get people at home to
donate I just please give please give
generously I don't know what else to say
I mean as part of our yearend funding
drive this is a really big time for us
in order to be able to get through um
this year um as you can imagine the
pandemic has hit us pretty hard and uh
anything anything can help us right now
and so um like I said if you want those
Panda dos I definitely would think you
should give us some money that's right
and and every uh individual contribution
qualifies for the end of your match
right now right so your contributions go
twice as far yep
fantastic okay James are you ready to
jump back into the next set of letters I
think we got to kind of keep to a
schedule here if we're gonna make this
four hours time limit we've got what 16
left no 11 left and we have an hour and
26 minutes so I better get to it you
better get give my letters all right
thanks Jeff and Katrina take care thanks
so much bye bye by
bye um
should I just go and tell go ahead and
tell you which ones that I want to do go
ahead all right well P we just talked to
Jeff it's going to be for pandas
okay Q is for
Q okay q q is in like Quay way that kind
of Q not the letter Q okay all right uh
R for
range okay uh s for static
method okay and T is for Tuple okay does
that sound good Jame got it does I'm so
glad you said Tuple and not Tuple oh
yeah wait is there a problem with
tupple there might
sever all right well James is getting
that ready you know um you heard it here
any donation helps uh go ahead and click
that donate Now button on tiltify uh
we're really trying to help numb focus
in there end of your giving campaign uh
donors over a hundred were are going to
be entered into a giveway away for
stickers and over 500 for a T-shirt and
we're trying to make this stretch goal
so that you can see Jim James's Vim RC
posted for real
um uh in in text that you can read on
Twitter so go ahead and help us out with
trying to achieve that stretch goal you
ready James can we can we say that if we
hit the 1250 stretch goal Jane will say
Tuple instead of Tuple for the next
three
months and I will be checking in on her
to ensure that she is not name tupling
anybody but name tupling them I feel
like there might be a violation of
privacy there somehow I that comes up in
in you know private conversation in my
home all the time and I don't know if I
want you involved in that okay okay okay
okay maybe validation is gonna be really
tricky on
this well that's why you use name tuples
not name Tuple then not uh just a
regular
Tuple for come on validate because okay
we'll get to it in the lightning talk
but we'll get to it get
it okay all right go ahead and share
your screen Take it
Away share my
screen okay I gotta start off with
pandas so let me update my screen
here
and let's get started let me switch over
to my other View and we'll talk about
the
pandas whoops talk about
pandas
so as we know panda is a num Focus
fiscally sponsored project um as Jeff
was saying that one of the things that
they've done in pandas recently has put
a lot of work into the extension array
type uh Pand is a library that
originally started as a bunch of
conveniences on top of a numpy and Dray
we've talked about numpy already as this
kind of restricted computation domain
that gives you the ability to view a raw
block of memory with some interpretive
layer and I want to show you broadly
what pandas is interesting about what
what makes pandas interesting and what
uh pandas is all about and there's one
thing that we'll touch upon in just a
moment when we touch upon range so
there's this will actually be split into
or part of the discussion of panas will
reoccur in one of the later lightning
talks as we know we an numpy and Dray
and the numpy and D represents some
machine typed contiguous block of values
and it's some mathematical type so that
if we perform operations on this
mathematical type for example double it
it actually does an element wise
operation and what Jeff was talking
about was the array type in pandas the
extension array type and the pandas
array as he said was a desire to remove
or to eliminate some of the dependence
the direct dependence on numpy and so
you can see here I have a pandas array
now when you think about a panda array
you might say well hold on a second you
know for the most part when I'm using
pandas I really am pretty much okay with
using num pies what does the array
really add to my life but one of the
most immediate things that array can add
to your life is if you take a look at
this Panda's array it contains two Nan
values two values indicating that
there's some missing data but it is
still an array of n64s where if we were
to try the same thing with A nump and D
array what we would see is that it would
accidentally have its type coerced to
being a float 64 if we look at the D
type here it'll be a float 64 dtype and
so one of the things that's missing from
the ND array directly is mass integer
types yes of course if you go into
numpy you can import I think is it I
can't remember what it's called so you
know import numpy ma but there is some
support for this in numpy itself but you
can see that the the value of you know
pandas here is providing some additional
supplementary information on top of
your I like to think of pandas as a
couple of things a bunch of conveniences
for uh working with columnar data sets
especially time series data sets a bunch
of and a set of types that provide you
with some business metadata on top of
some raw numerical data and so you can
see this immediately in the panda array
it's providing you some business
metadata namely the ability to mark that
some of the data is missing now if you
talk about the panda series you might
say from pandas import series and we
might take some numpy and Dr array and
we might put this into a series and I'll
show you one of the tricks that I really
like no I'll do that in a moment you
have some Panda series and you might say
well what's so interesting about this
Panda series now I told you when we
talked about the Len type that one of
the things that you do when you want to
implement a method from the python
object model from the data model is you
want to find the one unique privileged
way to express this idea and so if I do
a look up on this series you know you
might say okay there's one privileged
way to do the lookup on the series
whoops let's remove that and so here
this gives me the zeroth element from
the series or the first element from the
series the second element from the
series but it turns out that a series is
interesting because it has an index and
so you can see that this method this get
item method is actually ambiguous it's
either potentially looking something up
by its position or it's looking
something up by its label and if it
happens to be the case that the labels
are also numerical values then calls
like this may be ambiguous is this
looking up the is this looking up the
zeroth element or the element that
happens to be at the zeroth position and
the slicing notation
in comparison to the direct indexing
notation one of these is implicitly
working on the positions and one of
these is implicitly working on the uh
labels and so what pandas provides you
is a base type the series which gives
you this bimodality of lookup you can
look something up either by its position
or by its label subject to some index
and this index is merely a mechanism by
which you turn a key into a location in
the structure and so this is what the
lock and iock are in pandas the lock is
is look something up by its labeled
position and look the iock is looking
something up by its by its uh its
integer position by its row
number uh so this is look up by its
label and this I'd say this is look up
by the label and this is look up by the
position if you think about the last
major thing the last major type that's
available in pandas and there are some
other types that were there like the
panda. panel but that's really been
supplanted by the use of X arrays. array
but if you think about Panda's data
frame what the data frame gives you is a
doubly index structure so I'm going to
show you something kind of cute that I
like to do uh let's say this is a data
frame containing say financial data and
it has some tickers in it so here we'll
put a ticker but I can't really think of
any tickers to populate this with so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to use
a numpy and Dray I'm going to use Choice
from numpy I'm going to take a choice
from ask from the string module I'll
pull an asky
lowercase I'll say give me a choice of
all the letters uh in asky
lowercase and I'll say give this to me
in a size of uh 100 by two and then what
I want you to do is I want you to look
at this as a as a set of two a string
with two elements in it and I want you
to Ravel it so here we go we have a data
frame which happens to have some random
strings that we generated using numpy
and so it may often be the case that we
may not use and let's see do we get that
right and here we want to do Ravel and
yep that should be good and here we have
this is what I
wanted this is my ticker uh there's
something going wrong here I want this
to be of size here I want this like that
and let's see what I went on here and I
think I want to do I transpose it no
okay I gotta remember how I do that so I
guess I forgot how to do that
uh okay and then yes I want this to
be of this size 10 by3 maybe I want it
3x 10
and then I want this as oh I want this
view that's what I want I want it to be
viewed like this there we go yeah there
we go so we have a 10x4 and you can see
I can construct this really quickly all
at once with this ND array well what's
interesting about this is this structure
has an
index and it has another index The
Columns and so what you think is
interesting about a panda's data frame
is that it's a doubly index structure
it's an index down the rows and an index
across the columns and both of these
structures are both index types you can
see this range index here is just the
numbers from 0 to one if this happens to
have some you know financial data so
we'll do some just very quickly to wrap
this up we'll do something like this
normal we'll set this to the
size there we go size equals
size so here we have some information
here and we'll do a set index here on
this and we'll set ticker is the
index and here we go we should have some
normally distributed data it has an
index on it you can see the index is now
the string index representing the ticker
The Columns are an index representing
the columns themselves and you can think
of all the operations you could perform
on a on a data frame it's just being
some operations that are moving data
either within the actual data portion
which you can access like this this is
the block manager representing the
underlying data of the structure or from
the index to the columns or from the
columns to the index or from the index
to the data from the data to the columns
and these are what your operations like
stack unstack M pivot that's what those
operations really are they're just ways
to interoperate between these three or
to move data around or within these
different portions of the structure and
the data frame is really just a doubly
index structure it's just a
two-dimensional block of data with two
indexes two mechanisms by which you can
find either a column position or a row
position either by label or by its
numerical ordinal position so that's
pandas for you okay let's go on to our
next one which is the Q oh we're only on
number two
okay Q's what is interesting about Q's
well what's interesting about Q's are
it's what the only word in the English
language where every letter but the
first is silent but one of the things
that we can think about is that a python
stack is a pretty decent modeling for
something like
a uh the python list is a very
interesting is a very decent modeling
for for a last and first out structure
for a stack and if you wanted some kind
of Q Behavior you might go into the
collections do the collections module
and you have a collections. deck and the
collections. deck can model either a
stack or a Q and so if I say
collections. deck here I can pop or I
can pop from the left hand side and so
what I can do is I can use this either
as a stack or a Que Now one of the
things that I think is really
interesting is when you look at
algorithms like breath first search or
depth first search they're actually the
same underlying algorithm and the only
difference is what is the underlying
data structure which you're putting the
elements into and one you're putting
them into a stack the other one you're
putting them into a que and so there's a
way for you to formulate both breath for
search and depth for search as the same
algorithm let's see if I can do that off
the top of my head I don't know if I can
uh so let me say that I have some tree
and the tree is represented as a
dictionary where this is kind of your
network X style modeling where the keys
are the children so this is a and it has
a child called B and let's end it there
and then we'll say that this also has a
child called C
and let's make this go a little bit
deeper let me do this like this let's
say this has a child called C and we end
it there and A Child Called D and we end
it there so there we go and then there's
a child called e that has a child called
f so there we go okay and so this should
be a tree that looks like this it's got
a child B and E and the child
B has a c and
d and the child F has or the child e has
a child F and so let's see if we can
model this and so this should be like
that no let's see this has a and b put a
commment
there there we go I think that's right
okay and let's see if we can do a depth
for search and a breath for search in
two minutes so the depth for search
should give me
a b c
d EF
and the bread first should give me a b e
CDF okay so actually let me do a simple
let me do the simpler let me do a level
order traversal versus in order
traversal because that'll be a little
bit easier so a pre-order traversal of
this thing would be a b CDE e f right
and so we'll take our tree and we'll
make use
of uh yield from we'll do the foll we'll
print out the node that you're at so
we'll print out the current node that
you're at and we'll try this thing on
our tree and we'll start this from the
node a and I did these
lowercase okay and then I'll say for
child in tree of that node what I'll do
is I will yield from the pre-order of
the child of the of yeah of the here
like this and so here I'll yield
this and I think this should give me do
what I want and here I can do this in
one
line
so here we'll go down to
here okay there we go and we'll change
there we go
and this should be child there we go and
then this says if the child is in the
tree right this
go and we'll yield from it only
if no that should be
fine that should be fine oh and I guess
we have to we have to go with just go
deeper into this thing right yeah and
then we'll
say uh if child if tree of
node
no
yeah no we'll do
this just to make our modeling work
there we go so here we can see ABCDEF
ABCDEF that's exactly our pre-order
traversal our post-order traversal
should be basically the same
thing you know it just depends on where
we yield this thing so I think this
should just be our post order traversal
like this but our level order traversal
is actually the same underlying
algorithm it's just that instead of
using the implicit function call stack
we use a Q and so if I were to do
a BFS on this tree what I would expect
to do is I'd expect to use a
collections. deck I'd have this repres
present my
state right and then I'd say while I
have and I push into this thing the
initial node I'd say while State what
you do is you take the tree you take the
children from this Keys you'd extend
this thing with your
state and then you would
probably uh pop something out so you'd
say state.
pop left you'll pop something off the
left this is the node that you're going
to work on and then we'll yield this
thing and I think that should give us
something there although I have not done
this in a very long time so we'll see if
this works and if it doesn't then we
might just call it for this lightning
talk and see if we can do this now we're
missing one thing this should be a deck
not a
Q and the last thing is we have to see
if the node is
in oh and we have to measure oh this is
okay so we'll do tree node like that
that's what we have to do there
and
then something like that
maybe and then here this gives us the
actual underlying object we pull that
out then we extend that with the keys No
we' extend this with the items so this
would be the key and
the
that yeah this uh this modeling is quite
quite atrocious so here we want
to yeah we want to extend that there the
modeling of this thing is not that great
so let's see if we can get this done in
the remaining SEC couple seconds we have
before we have to move on or we might
have to come back to this because we are
almost out of time and so I think we may
have to come back to this one with the
the stack versus Q because I think we're
out of time on this wish I could have
gotten that one done but one failed out
of all the other ones we've done not too
bad let's move on to the range and the
range is I think think a little bit
easier for us to talk about what we may
find is that there is a consistency in
Python with its interval notation and
the interval notation in
Python let's restart and we're going to
talk about interval notation when we
talk about range and so uh when we see
the range object in Python the range
object in Python uses an a closed open a
half open interval notation goes up to
but does not include its end point so if
I try and dump this into a list using my
kep 448 additional unpacking
generalizations I'll see the value zero
but I won't see the value 10 and this
consistency of the interval notation is
is pretty thorough in Python so for
example before I was I was deliberating
between whether to use Rand int or Rand
range and Rand int is one of the rare
cases in which we
see in which we see this interval
notation not
being obeyed in other words if we do a
Rand int between Z and two will actually
see the two value whereas if we do a
Rand range between 0 and two we'll never
see that two value and if we look at the
help text for Rand range we'll see that
this is explicitly called out in that
help text because it says it fixes the
problem with Rand int which includes the
endpoint and that's not usually what you
want in Python and the exclusion of the
endpoint is something that we see quite
consistently in Python for example in
our slicing notation we can see that if
we slice to three and I'll make this a
I'll make this a little bit
clearer what we can see is we will incl
we will go up to but not including the
third character and so you can think
this is the zero first second third we
won't include that third character but I
can show you one or two places where
this is not uh obey um from
numpy
import Lin space Lin space will not will
include its endpoint so this is a linear
space with a certain number of samplings
so here I have a linear space with say
101 samplings from 0o to one to 10 and
this will actually include 10 as its end
point you can see there so this is one
common place where you'll see that open
close interval notation in addition to
the randant is not is not uh preserved
but this doesn't really represent like a
slicing or a subsetting operation and so
we'd expect every time we do a slicing
or subsetting operation this closed open
interval notation would be preserved but
there's another place where we see that
it's not preserved and this goes back to
our Panda series as I said what's
interesting about the panda series is
that the panda series gives you a b
modality of lookup you can look up
elements either by their position or by
their index label and so here I have a
series object with the labels a b and c
and if I print this out you can see it's
just one two and three with the labels a
b and c and if I slice it using the
basic notation here you can see this is
giving me an implicit uh operation and
actually let me change this to something
like this 10 20 30 you can see this
works implicitly on the position
positions not on the labels and you can
see this obeys our regular notation of
okay don't include the endpoint if I use
lock and iock I can be a little bit more
specific about the modality that I want
whether I want uh to look things up by
its position or it's by its label and if
I do this specifically by the eyelock we
can see okay everything's hunky dory
everything's fine but if I switch this
back to my index with non-numeric values
and I do the Dot Lock and I say give me
this Panda series up to
but including or not including the C you
can see oh hold on a second this I this
lock lookup in pandas gives us a closed
closed interval it's closed on both ends
it includes the end point and this
happens
irrespective irrespective of whether
this happens to
be a numeric or non-numeric index and
you might wonder why is that that's kind
of strange because if and you can see
here this me the label three and so you
can see the label three was included let
me actually make these things match up
so you can see that there really is
something interesting Happening Here we
get different values for the lock up to
two and for the iock up to two it
includes the endpoint on the lock
accessor and the reason for that is that
lock accessor in pandas looks at the
labels of the index and the labels of
the index are not guaranteed to be
totally ordered in fact the pandas index
even knows certain characteristics of
itself like its monotonicity
I think it's like this monotonic and
this is something that is taken into
consideration when you do slicing
notation in terms of what are you going
to return a single Val a single row or
multiple rows and if the index is not
monotonic certain operations may or may
not work on that certain slicing
operations may or may not work certain
indexing all the oper indexing
operations should work in any case
because the labels of the panda series
are not guaranteed to have a total
ordering and because the labels are not
guaranteed to have some natural
successive mechanism like numeric values
are like the next value is always a
Value Plus One well the only choice they
really had was to implement lock to
include the endpoint and to violate this
convention that we see in range Rand
range in slicing notation on python
lists and even the notation in slicing
on the iock accessor in other words if
we take our series object and we do a
lock on this and it has a value C we
have to include that value because
otherwise may not be possible for us to
say oh give me the next value how do we
actually increment this to get to the
next value whereas if we were to do an
iock accessor it always easy to get the
endpoint we just do a plus one and
oftentimes when I'm writing code I may
in fact use Rand range and if I wanted
to get all the values up to but but and
including 10 I might write it like this
to make it very clear that I understand
the open close interval notation I
understand that this won't include the
end point but I intend for it to include
the end point I intend to go one over
and this is why panda. loock disobeys
this interval
notation okay that was a little bit
better let's go next into
our static
method and so let's reset our
clock and we'll go into our static
method now for the static method uh this
is one of the common decorators that we
see in use on on classes so the comma
Decor that we see in use tend to be what
property you know class method and
static method and when I told you about
the uh descriptor this descriptor
protocol when we talked about get Adder
what I showed you was that the
descriptor protocol says when you
retrieve something from an object if
that thing happens to have a get method
then you do something special and what
you do special is you call the get
method with some special arguments this
is how instance methods work in Python
this is how class methods work in Python
but one thing that you might be
surprised about in Python is the
following if I do this if I say create a
function Fu it takes aelf but does not
belong to a class and then I create a
class and I say FU equals Fu first that
is very weird this typically should not
work given the way that python binds
variable names but this will in fact
work and I can do
this yeah that works and I can do
this import lad s and I can do
this uh let's see what's count but take
a look at this let's load from a string
this is a Json load s that
fails because it says wait there's too
many arguments that you're passing in
but this
works and the way that static method
works is it implements a get and that
get just doesn't really do anything
interesting it's really not that
interesting how static method Works what
more interesting is how python functions
work all functions written in pure
python are in
fact things that implement the
descriptor protocol all python functions
Implement that descriptor protocol and
so when you have a class and you have a
function under that class and you do X
of T like this or x equals T and then x.
Fu or x.f like this it's going to look
this thing up it's going to realize it
has that get method it's going to invoke
that get method and that get method is
going to put in that self property
that's how the self gets added to python
functions it's done by the descriptor
get function on all functions written in
Python in Python 2 you used to have this
bound Unbound method dichotomy that was
eliminated in Python 3 there's no such
thing as a bound versus Unbound method
in Python in Python 3 and Python 3 it's
just that there's a descriptor protocol
behind all of your functions that you
have and when you invoke a function it
just goes through the descriptor
protocol to insert that self well if we
go back to this example the reason why
this works is this function was already
a method that could have been bound and
so here the only weird the only little
audity here is something like this
really shouldn't work typically you know
there's a distinction between whether
this is a uh a local variable or a
global variable and in the body of the
class this is evaluated uh managing to
get around that this said take a
function written in another module that
happens to be written in pure python
bring it into the namespace of the class
and now it looks like a method that's on
the class but because it was written in
pure python it has a descriptor protocol
on it and thus when I try and invoke it
I'm passing too many arguments because
that descriptor protocol will be invoked
put in that self and I'll say hold on a
second you want me to do a load s on
self that makes no sense whatsoever but
in this case that iter tools. count
because it tools. count was written in C
it the C function did not have the get
method on it did not have that
descriptor protocol enabled and as a
consequence when you looked that up on
the class you got just the regular C
function back and it worked perfectly
didn't insert the self argument and then
you could just say next to that and so
you can see that what's interesting
about class meth about static method
isn't really anything the static method
is really just something that says you
know
what my get just doesn't do anything
just return the function itself so here
you can see self instance owner this
would just say you know return self. F
and it won't do anything fancy so I'll
see if I can Implement instance method
and class me and static method for you
directly here we say class T static
method def Fu doesn't take any arguments
we'll return Fu we'll create an ins of
this of this thing and we'll call
it there you go that's all static method
does and I'll even call it something
different so you can see that it is my
static method that's all static method
does and instance methods you know
here's my instance method all it does is
it binds it sort of like
this
there we go that's all it does and you
can think class method is very similar
so here this is a instance
method there you go and if you want a
class method I'll even give you a class
method because I have 30 seconds
remaining and I'm still upset that I
couldn't get the q1 going we're going to
definitely revisit that one if only for
sake of personal pride and so here this
would just be the
owner I believe is all that's going to
pass through there you go so that's
something like a class method
um the class method I can't remember if
it takes to runtime type it's either the
owner or it's the type of the instance
so uh I think it takes
the runtime type so I think it's like
this uh that that I have to quickly
check but we're out of time and so maybe
we'll check that in a future lightning
talk and so you can see if you can just
put a small note on that there's a
distinction in Python between the static
type for where a function is defined and
the runtime type of the function that's
actually invoking that
path
okay lastly tupes or as Jane likes to
say two plays or if the folks at home
donate enough money we can make her say
at least for the next month bear in mind
she may be on vacation for the next
month and so that might uh that might
not be as big a win as as we'd like but
still Folks at home let's get donating
let me restart my timer and we will talk
about the tupal often times I like to
ask people about lists and tuples
because I think that really
understanding the fundamental types in
Python does help us become better python
programmers and I like to ask them okay
what is the difference between list in a
tuple because I think it really forces
somebody to think about what these
things actually are what they mean in a
very similar sense maybe we'll have time
to talk about the difference between a
string and a list and I think this is a
very interesting question it looks like
a very silly question what's the
difference between the first option and
the second option well obviously one's a
string and the other one's a list but
they contain the same data and so what
you can think is the list is that data
with some outof band structuring
mechanism that delimits where one item
begins and the other item ends and the
string has some inband structuring
mechanism namely the commas that delimit
as part of the data not part of some
metadata where one element begins and
ends and if you think about it like that
you can also think that a function that
returns three values is distinct from a
generator that yields three values
because the generator is that same
computation but it has an outof band
structuring mechanism to split that
computation into Parts whereas the
function you really can't tell where
part of the one computation ends the
other one begins and you really can't do
anything mechanically with this via the
python interpreter you can't say oh
partially evaluate this function whereas
the generator gives you that structuring
that linear structuring just like the
list gives you linear structuring on the
string and breaks it down into parts
that you can then iterate over but what
I'm supposed to show you here is a
difference between a list and a tupal
well oftentimes people when they look at
that tupal they say oh you know it's
just like a list except you can't mutate
it and the thing that's most interesting
about that tupal is that it is immutable
and I don't think that that's the case
because I think that I can make an
immutable list that's not too hard
instead of list. append I would just
have something like this here's some
value and I just do something like this
or list. extend you know
here and here's some y's and you know
look this is always making a copy and so
this is this is my new list type and it
is
immutable and so clearly if I can do
that I wonder if in two minutes I can
show you how to mutate a tuple that's
actually not too hard because numi is
a view of memory what I should be able
to do is I should be able to take the
let's give a tupal here say one two
none4 five uh let's find the ID of the
Tuple let's Create A numpy and D array
that's
empty uh we know where that numpy and D
array sits in memory so here we can ask
this let's do this x is equals that we
can take the ID of the Tuple and the
nump dray should be earlier on in space
so we'll do uh array info
we'll take a look at the data and we'll
take a look at zero and this is the
offset between the numpy and Dray and
the Tuple and let's see if that's a
positive offset and this is what the
what is this the array array
info what is that
called so that's
the array interface sorry o we should
know
that
this is the array interface there we go
and you can see that's the that's the
distance between the Tuple and where
that exists so what I can do is I can
use as strided to take this thing to
make it look much larger than it is and
so here I'll I'll provide the strides
the strides will be one I'll say this is
now a and I'll make this an N64 a u64 d
type that'll help me a lot uh equals
uint 64 we'll make the strides equal to
one and we'll make the size equal to the
offset plus one so here what I can do is
I can stretch all the way from where my
and this is the shape yeah I can stretch
all the way from where my numpy and Dray
is down to the tup where the tupal is
and once I do that I can take this
structure and I can set the strides
equal to and let's strut yeah let's go
by one bite at a time let's say eight
bytes and I think what I want to do is I
want to offset this by three so I think
that's what the header of this structure
looks like so let's see if I can get
this to work and this would be uh from
no this is going to be
from we're going to go from there all
the way to the end so what we want to do
is we want to take this from the offset
to the end and then we're going to say
this is three elements I believe and so
this should take us right to the the
head of this thing and then once we're
at the head of this thing this should
take us
to uh zs3 like this strides equals one I
think that's what no
that's no I want strides eight here I
believe and then shape should be
the length of the
tupal so let's see if that gave us what
we
wanted yeah there we go that's the 1
three and that's the none value and I
think think we have yep there we go
we're a little bit far so I think we
take this
from n let's see where do we want to go
we're a little bit too far here so the
shape of this thing is at four well
there we go we can see one of these is
this this here should be the none value
that we saw and so if we do WS of one
equals the idea of the number
three then
we will either core dump or we'll have
updated the Tuple but you can see this
technique is a little bit harder to Live
code than you think because oh no those
are the IDS of so that's going to be the
count of this thing so I think I'm lost
a little bit in the object but what you
can see is you can go ahead and mutate
this so there you go tupal is uh not
necessarily interesting because it's
mutable or immutable the tupal is
interesting because there something
fundamentally different than the list
what that is may have to wait for the
next lightning talk
okay that was a rush but I think we got
through those I think you
did and uh I I think that the audience
is responding as well because we are so
close to our next stretch goal so we're
trying to get to 1750 so that James will
post his vimrc to Twitter and we are
currently at 1685 we had a couple of uh
Big Ticket donors as well as some
smaller amounts and so everything counts
um if we get to the 1750 goal remember
that these uh these donations go twice
as far because they're part of the end
ofe giving Don uh campaign that's a
mouthful
huh so that one more time what is this
end ofe giving campaign it's a match so
when you donate $ five it counts as $10
if you donate $20 it counts as $40 so
your giving is going twice as far
because because of a a donor match a
corporate match that uh num Focus has
secured for all of their individual
donations so all of your individual
corporate your your individual
contributions today count towards that
match well thanks for reminding us of
that great time of year to make
donations um and now I get to introduce
our final guest speaker for the day Tom
Caswell who uh is a fellow part of the
National Lab system he's out at Brook
Cen um and also the bdfl for met plot
lib I am I live you
are sorry did not nothing changed I
wasn't sure if I was on screen um right
thank you for having me actually one of
a we've recently changed the title of
bdfl to Project Lead because
um that that's a bdfl is a funny inside
joke but we're there's some people when
you tell it to you get very strange
looks back um
so just m the I had to do it I mutated I
got it
working oh I got James the stereo there
uh so uh so uh from the point of view of
M plot lib num focus is a giant a giant
lever that we can we can use um so these
projects a lot of them started from
Individual people you know trying to
solve their own problems um
start with John Hunter trying to make
plots to look at um
EG's um and over time these just grew
and you grew this large international
team of people who are working on this
code um but was really no good home
institution no infrastructure around it
uh and num focus is a thing that
provides that infrastructure for us uh
in terms of like really concrete things
this provides for us is um even long
before the pandemic like we were fully
remote fully distributed uh primarily
interacting through text on GitHub and
mailing lists and at some point we
started trying to do regular developer
calls once a week um and not having any
institution or anything we were just
doing this on like Google Hangouts on
personal accounts which you know works
but it's very um you know it's Scrappy
um and so something that Matt that num
Focus has provided for us is access to a
corporate Zoom account so that we can
make sure those meetings happen every
week independent of who was actually
able to show up that week or Not Right
There Was You know when it was hosted
off of uh my Google account I couldn't
make the meeting one week and we just
didn't have the meeting because I
couldn't get on and start the you know
and start the call
um another things is that I said we're
mostly volunteer and you
know that gets you pretty far like we
can do you can do a lot of really good
stuff on pure volunteer but there's some
problems that just are better handled by
a paid developer they need more time
than a volunteer can put in or they need
you know 16 hours of dedicated effort or
they're just the kinds of things that
aren't fun and that you can't it's hard
to get someone excited about doing like
taking care of the CI
um and so he okay so we should start
getting some funding and have paid
developers and this leaves the question
of like so let's assume we get money
what do we do with it right a foundation
is not going to write me a check to pay
somewhat like like the you know they're
you know they're not they have rules
about how they can spend their money to
make sure it gets spent appro L and so
you need some institution to take that
money uh if you look at our development
our developer team we spread across
across many institutions across the
world uh so you know whose home
institution does it go to uh is that
home institution going to let the money
go back out to pay a contractor like do
we have to hire like all of the
developers at one institution it just
gets
very as you start looking at this you
get more questions than answers um and
you know
uh and num Focus serves that role as the
you know as a neutral home institution
that can take money from foundations and
granting agencies uh they can manage our
payroll they handle all the details
behind the scenes to make sure that
these donations are tax deductible you
know if you wanted to give me money that
just like to me and make it tax
deductible I have no idea how I would do
that
um
um and I'm sure there are details behind
the scenes that num folks has taken care
of on the finance and business side that
I don't even know I don't know um and
concretely so Matt plot has been lucky
enough to uh get uh grants from Chan
Zuckerberg uh last year and this year to
fund uh two people full-time Hana Ean
working on uh M pob as her thesis to lay
it out the foundation of for the the
library going forward and uh iiot Sals
Andre who's working as a full-time
engineer maint you know doing the hard
work of maintaining like keeping the
lights on and keeping the project going
um and that you know the process of
receiving that money and distributing it
back out to the people who need to get
it uh would not have been possible
without n Focus um on the smaller side
right we've also um been able to take
advantage of the small development
grants to great effect um one of the
things we funded was uh Nicholas roier
to write up some map plot Li cheat
sheets um Nicholas Ro is probably the
best map plot Li user in the world right
now the stuff he makes is just beautiful
and if you go to github.com molp Che
sheets we have I think four pages of um
Illustrated examples of how to how to do
things you know the basic things you
would want with M flot lib um another
thing we did with the small development
grants is we have a fair number of
platform specific bugs right so
something can be you know there's a bug
on a Mac that you know only shows up on
Macs um or on Windows or you know and on
Linux depending on what the bug is
um not all of our developers have access
to all those machines so we we have a
small development grant that funds a Mac
Mini and Mac stadium that allows all of
our developers to get access to a Mac
when we needed to book that sort of
thing
um and I
guess oh uh
um a personal level I think D Focus
um uh being an over developer can can be
very isolating uh most of our feedback
from our users is bug reports or
complaints you know we get our users the
users communicate communicate with us
when they're at their most frustrated uh
angriest the library is broken State um
and one of the things through attending
the Pata events I remember having a
conversation with Brett Canon on a
couple years ago at Piata New York where
I comment on how like you know people
walk up and you say like oh the library
is great and you're like are you sure
we're talking about the same Library
that's not the usual feedback I get and
Brett said you know whenever I feel that
way I think to these conferen you look
out and there's you know 500 a, people
here who are using the tools we built
and are very happy and that that um on a
personal level was very valuable to me
to like keep going through you
know some of the harsher feedback
Wonder thank you so much for sharing
that Tom um yeah it's true I mean I
think uh you know map plot lib is one of
the tools that we all depend on right
and even if there's uh you know another
another layer on top of it like
ultimately map lot Li is powering a lot
of these tools right so I I think it's
really powerful and it shows the scale
that open source can reach that you know
we can say these names like pandas mat
plot lib Jupiter and everyone knows what
it is is right like people people are
interacting with this daily in their
work and it's making a big difference in
science um James Jane do you have any uh
any chitchat for
Tom James you're
muted so I absolutely do so Matt PL lib
just like pandas is another recipient of
small development grants and also
recipient of the Chan Zuckerberg uh
grants and the larger grants obviously
are going to very large scale things but
Tom could you briefly talk about where
some of the money that folks are
donating might go to help support
matplot lib and also can you teach me
how subplots works I can teach you how
subplots work and actually I um there's
been a I'm going to do a Shameless plug
for new features um in 32 we we got a
new layout engine that does a much
better job of laying out the subplots in
33 we we got subplot Mosaic which let
you draw asy art um representations of
your subplots to build uneven grids and
in 34 we're going to get a concept of
subfigure which will allow you do to do
even more deeply nested complex layouts
um uh so in terms of where the the small
money goes the cheat sheets are one of
the big ones um that's those are
beautiful and we need to do a better job
of Market of of making them known um
the and just some of the underlying
infrastructure stuff that has to happen
so the the Mac Stadium Mac uh we have a
discourse that we that we self host on
digital ocean and we may need to start
paying for some dedicated CI in some
cases and all those are the sorts of
things that would be amenable to a small
development Grant
uh that's fantastic so it sounds like
for the folks at home watching along if
they choose to donate in addition to to
getting a copy of my heavily edited and
redacted Vim RC uh and maybe even some
other benefits that maybe Tom might
provide his emac config if we can compel
him to uh and Tom will also uh make sure
that subplots and the rest of mpot lib
actually works because mpot lib can
pretty much do everything and also it
can do everything in two or three
distinct different ways to do everything
uh this money can go to be make to
actually make the tools that you use
every day easier to use easier to
understand better documented this money
goes to something that will genuinely
benefit not only your life but the life
of the millions of users the scientists
who are using these tools the data
scientists the physical scientists the
uh machine learning experts who are
using these tools every day James I
thought you were also going to mention
that we already met our initial stretch
goal which means that all donors today
will be included in a very special poll
request that you are submitting for a
num Focus themed color map to mat flot
live which may or may not be merged it
will be we'll go through the standard
review
process that's most we that's all we can
ask
for well and um so so you do uh want to
make your donation you don't want to
miss out on that opportunity you don't
want to miss out on James's vmrc reveal
uh for real on Twitter
uh that's only if we meet our 1750
stretch goal right now we're at
1685 um so you know every every little
bit counts every little bit goes to help
the projects I can throw in
myx if that's if that if that's
something that would help move move the
needle yeah can you can you show us our
your RC
config
uh your RC pams I guess you call it your
map plot Li RC I I never set NRC prams
file
um because uh it is very pragmatic
because if I do it is possible that I
would be masking out beh Behavior users
are seeing so I want to make sure my
when trying to reproduce bugs I'm not
confusing myself by debugging a
different situation than than the user's
running
but that seems very reasonable
um okay I don't want I think that James
is actually stalling for time because he
doesn't want to do the last six letters
of the
alphabet um I do think that we need to
probably jump into that quickly um thank
you so much for coming Tom it really
means a lot to hear directly from the
projects especially the project leads uh
so really appreciate you coming here
today and spending part of your Saturday
with us thank you for having me please
every little bit
helps help us help you and um should we
should we tie your emac to the current
stretch goal as well sure okay fantastic
so you will get James's vimrc you'll get
Tom's uh emac setup and uh we'll we'll
see how we can how that goes and Jane
saying two play for a month yeah and
I'll I'll do okay okay to play you have
to say it very
fancily oh yeah she
agre to that
okay and I I'll show you my Jupiter
setup how about that
oh oh and I just got a text message from
Leah silen who is our first guest
apparently we have given away the num
Focus board has given
$150,000 on small development grants
just this year to improve small areas of
the projects small areas that are maybe
difficult to find large institutional
funding for as the afor mentioned doc
improvements uh cheat sheets things like
that $150,000 of SG funding is what I'm
told and so every little bit helps to
improve the projects that you use every
day it's
amazing okay thanks so much Tom I'm
going to launch directly into um before
we announce the final qu final letters I
know that there's some trivia that's
been going on in the background so we
had the question about uh Julia it was
uh in what year was the Julia project
first funded by num Focus the answer of
course is
2014 and our our winner on that is again
lightseeker on Twitter thanks so much
for following along and participating uh
I think we have maybe just the one more
trivia question for you and so this is
also going to be posted on Twitter reply
to us at dutc unor tring and use the
hashtag J cjames sweat hash cjam sweat
to answer the following question uh what
two-word Easter egg command brings up a
PO when you when using python what can
you type into your your console and get
a poem out like an e coming style poem
because it doesn't rhyme right yeah yeah
well you know the broader sense of
poetry not not like a not the narrow
rhyming sense yeah not an rhyming
sense I'm excited to learn the answer to
that one yeah there's many Easter eggs
in Python um are there many Easter eggs
in
Julia I can't think of things like that
off the top of my head but maybe I'm
just not in the no so I will say this
one to stall for
time uh if we hit our next stretch goal
and I don't know what that is um I will
write a limeric live either in this
session if we have time or in a future
session about python because you may not
know this about me but I used to spend a
lot of my free time writing rhyming
poetry I did not know that and actually
I've just been informed that we just met
our uh our stretch goal of 1750 so I am
upping it to 2500 if you want to hear
James WR a limmerick uh help us get to
2500 the Vim reveal is coming the color
map is
coming uh Tom's Tom's emac is coming
what other things do we promis we promis
the the pub quiz is coming so all of
these things have already been achieved
and unlocked uh now making Jane seem
nuts in front of her co-workers by
saying to play for a month that's coming
oh yeah yeah yeah and and definitely J
Jane's definitely gonna do that
so so let's jump into the letters are
you ready James for the last stretch we
got a we're a little bit over time here
it's already 5:45 but I think people
will will be okay with you going to
6:15 can okay let's
I think I can do it I think we'll go I
think I'll go as fast as I can I'm doing
okay on time so far by the way and the
only disappointment so far is that
stupid pre modeling for the Q the BFS
it's so clumsy but I got the tupal
mutated and so at least I'm worth that
and so just before we jump into it I
would love to show people my little
hacky I did this live for you on screen
this is how you can mutate a tupo that's
supposed to be immutable in numpy that's
the code right there the only thing that
I was missing is one of the uh stri
should have been eight instead of one
and so let me unshare my screen let's
jump into those last letters and let's
do it because I have as much energy as
when we started Lauren what are my last
letters fantastic U is for
underscore okay V is for Value
error okay W for
walrus okay X for xarray okay Y is for
yield from okay and Z Jane said it
earlier today it's got to be
zip okay so we have zip uh yield
from we have oh I used yeld from the
last one
xray wall walrus for the I guess that's
the what what we call the assignment
expression added in Python 3.7 and U for
underscore I got it and V for Value
error did you get oh and V for Val yep
yeah no they're doing six this
round finish it
off okay I'm queued up I'll share my
screen and let me switch
over I am ready to
go okay
underscore uh and you know I have to
think of something interesting to say
for each of these so let's jump right
into it with you for underscore okay so
one of the things that you might have
seen in Python code is that sometimes
people write code that looks like this
they say for underscore in range 10 you
might wonder wonder what that is and it
turns out that there's a convention
among python programmers namely that the
underscore sorry you gotta you gotta
start over because we can't see your
screen uh oh just start over from the
top yeah share your screen I have to
remember what I was talking about what
was I talking about
again okay you for underscore so you may
have seen before in Python code written
by I guess py on programmers is what I
was saying is that there is this
convention where you'll see code that
looks like for underscore in range 10
and this underscore is just a convention
that people say in order to indicate
that oh we don't really care about this
variable because if you wrote code that
looked like this for X in range 10 and
you never used X in the loop and
somebody looking that would be like hold
on a second why did you care about
giving the name to this variable if
nobody's actually using it and so you
may find that you might choose an
underscore and similarly with the pep
448 additional unpacking generalizations
you may see code that looks like this
you know here's the head of a list and
then here's the rest of the list instead
of writing Rest like this to unpack the
remaining elements I'll say you know
what I only care about looking at the
very first element of the structure or
if I only cared about looking about the
first element and the last element of
the structure you can see this code very
nicely conveys that you're only trying
to extract The Head and the tail but not
the rest but the underscore also has
another meaning in python in the
interactive console here we go the
underscore sometimes the underscore
refers to the last computered expression
and you may be surprised that in your
juper notebook it's the very same case
because Jupiter notebook uses your
IPython kernel so in other words if I
compute 10 plus 20 and I say this plus
one that's just the value of the last
expression kind of like that button on
your calculator this ISS now the reason
why this exists is let's say we have
some function that is very very slow so
I'll use my from time import sleep and
we have some function that is very slow
and it sleeps for two seconds and it
returns a value and you call this
function and you're like oh darn I just
wasted two seconds of my time I got to
call it again because I want this
expression well I could say x equals
that but then I'm paying the cost of
calling this function again or instead
what I could do is I could say oh x
equals underscore and then I don't have
to waste that time two seconds is not a
lot of time to to pay but if you're on
the clock for a FIV minute lightning
talk well it's already a lot what you
might also notice is here I'm using my
IPython console not my the reppel that
comes with the interactive sorry the
rippel that comes with the in the
standard library or it comes with
cpython itself and what you might see is
on the side of my screen this in and out
and you may not have looked really
closely What In and Out are those square
brackets are actually indexes in is a
list a python list of strings that
correspond to all of the input that you
have put into your IPython console or if
you happen to be used your Jupiter
notebook with a Python 3 IPython kernel
your Jupiter notebook meaning if you
ever have a cell in your jupyter
notebook and you accidentally do
something in that cell and you delete
the cont of that cell but if you've run
it at least one time you can look
through this inst structure and find all
the previous input that you had in the
structure so here you can see here these
are all the previous lines that I wrote
now I'm going to do one quick thing here
and I'll show you something that you
might have run into I'm going to run my
I'm going to run my IPython under a u
limit with a limited amount of memory
and when I do that you will see another
thing that sometimes catches people up
if I have a numpy and Dray and that
numpy and Dray is very large and I'm
using a jupyter notebook especially
because what we know is when we're using
our jupyter notebook we often times
don't want to use that print state
directly we'd rather either set you know
our interactive mode so that every
single uncaptured expression gets
printed in that out with the nice pretty
PR format with a pretty formatting or we
use I python. display. display to get
that pretty formatting so we can have
that HTML formatting on our pandas data
frames well what we often do is we'll
leave the last expression of the cell to
be the thing that we want to look at so
that it triggers that really nice
formatting and so instead of writing
some code that looks like you know
normal size equals 10,000 th000 like
this and we print it out to the screen
rather than doing a print x's and when
we do that it gets captured in this out
variable and the out variable is not a
set of strings it is a it's not a list
of strings it is a dictionary mapping
these string in the or the position in
the in variable like in of three
to the actual python object of the
output which means if this object is
very very very very large this is this
out is just a normal dictionary so if
this object is very large and I don't
use it anymore I Dell X is it it is
still in my memory right here on that
out structure and so if you happen to
have a jupyter notebook or an IPython
console and it seems to get slower and
you're loading large pieces of memory
you need to restart it every so often
maybe the reason is that you're out has
captured some very large data structure
and hasn't cleaned it out and there is a
way that you can clean this out do an
xell instead of a Dell of this structure
and I think I called it oh let me create
it again do an X Dell of this structure
and it will be removed from the out as
well as any other places that it might
have been cached in your IPython or
Jupiter notebook so that's underscore
let us move on to our next letter our
next letter is value error and let me
restart my timer and we'll go right into
value error
Okie
doie
restart ready to go now value error is
one of the errors that we run into when
we have some you know we have some
function and we pass in some bad value
and so for example what we'll see is if
I happen to have some function called
mean and what it's going to do is it's
going to compute the mean of a set of
numbers just by taking the sum and
dividing by the length and if this
structure happens to to be empty what I
might do is I might say if not X's
because I'm assuming this is a python
structure not an npy and D array then I
might raise a special error and I might
raise a value eror and the reason I
might choose a value error is this
happens to be the right type of input if
this happens to be an empty list it's
just a bad it's a bad value of that
particular type this will work but this
won't work because it'll be a divide by
zero so I might raise a value error
value error in itself is not that
interesting you can think of the
standard errors that we have we have
things like value error meaning
something passed a value that was bad we
have type error meaning you pass
something that irrespective what the
value of that type was it would never
have worked and so for example asking
for the mean of a string this is
meaningless right how do you it's not a
numeric value that should be a this
should be a value and of course here you
can see this should sorry that should be
a type error but what I think is very
interesting to talk about that tiing is
something that we talked about before is
not value error or type error but key
error and index error index error a
little bit less so this is the error
that we see if we have a python list and
we index it with some index that doesn't
exist but I want to talk to you a little
bit about key error and I want to show
you why key error I think is the way
that it is if you happen to have a
python dictionary and in that dictionary
maybe a dictionary like that out that
you see in your I python kernel if you
happen to have a python dictionary and
in that python dictionary you try to
look for something that doesn't exist
what does python do well python signals
that I couldn't find that thing and you
might be aware that in that in Python
with the python dictionary you can do a
d. getet and you can get something out
and if it doesn't exist in this thing
it'll be replaced by a default value and
if you don't specify the default value
you'll see a none as a default value and
you might wonder why is it that python
doesn't use this.get Behavior by default
well when you think about it whenever
you have a lookup for a lookup there's
always two possible modes for a lookup
either you found the thing you looking
for found it or you didn't find
it and if you didn't find the thing
there's two ways to signal that you
didn't find the thing you can either
signal this inband or you can signal
this out of band you can either signal
this with some particular value or you
can signal this through some other
mechanism if you signal this with some
particular value like it's done in
JavaScript or even in the shell for
example you say okay I'm going to always
return a NV value like get does then it
is possible for somebody to mistakenly
try to process that value for example if
I do D.G C so I can avoid that key error
and then I try and add one to it like I
could if I did d. getb I will see an
error but it'll be a different type of
error than the error that I should have
seen here it'll be a type error because
I can't add none to one it'll instead a
and what I really probably wanted was a
key because if I trigger this key I'll
see the error occur on the line at the
place where the error actually occurred
the lookup failed I couldn't do anything
with the result of this lookup and so it
is often the case that when we are
working with a dictionary it may be the
case that there is no meaningful way to
continue the program's normal mode of
operation if you look something up in
that dictionary and you can't find it a
canonical example for this would be like
an englishto Spanish dictionary you know
if you had a very simple englishto
Spanish dictionary and you did something
with the contents of this dictionary for
example you looked up an English word
and then you wanted to print something
out here's the corresponding Spanish
word and you wanted to do something with
this you can say to
say the English word in Spanish you say
the Spanish word there is no way that I
can change this from being an inband so
from being an outof band representation
of it something being missing like if I
look up three that's not in this
dictionary there's no way for this
program to continue running so if I just
switch this to the inband mechanism the
get the guard the out is garbage and if
I were to try and do something to the
output I have traded one error that
should have occurred on this line for
another error that occurred on this line
and so what I would say about key error
is this all of these error types and the
design of how these exceptions are
raised in Python is designed very
thoroughly in order to eliminate
ambiguities don't look at exceptions say
oh these These are only for exceptional
circumstances oh I don't really want to
deal with these exceptions I'll try and
find some ways around them I'll try and
swap them out with error codes or I'll
try to swap them out with error values
because what you will often find is when
you try to do an inband signaling
mechanism for an error like this it is
very easy to either one accidentally
miss that you got this error and two to
properly disambiguate the two situations
that you found the thing or you didn't
find the thing because it is very much
the case in a python dictionary even
though in this particular sense it does
not even in this particular case it does
not make sense it is very much the case
that a python dictionary contain any
object up to an including a none and so
here you would not be able to
disambiguate did I look the thing up and
find it and got a none or did I look the
thing up and it wasn't there and I got a
none this is why K exists this is why
signals this is why dictionary signal
keyn not or keynot found with an outof
band mechanism using key error which is
related to Value error because that's
what I could think of to say that might
be interesting about this topic let us
move on
to
wallus and I'll reset my
timer and then we'll go now the walrus
that Lauren is referring to to is
something that was added in Python 3.6
which is this assignment expression as
we may know python has a statement as
has a expression statement dichotomy in
its language design and its grammar
design in other words there are things
that are statements such as you know
defining a function defining a class
uh uh historically print was a statement
until it became a function in Python 3
also things like for
Loops or while loops
these are all these are all what are
called statements they're things that
perform some action and they are in and
also assignment so here assignment is
another example and this is in contrast
to things that compute values like
arithmetic expressions or string
operations or other method calls or
function calls that comput a value or
indexing operations or lookup operations
these are all things that compute values
now
it is historically the case that
assignment and even what you might call
selection were part of
the statement side of the language but
python quite a while back I sometime in
Python 2 added a tary if else which is
not just a a shorthand form for an if
else it's not just a Shand form but it's
actually an introduction of this
selection mechanism into the expression
language and so you can say as an
expression you know X if 2 is greater
than one else y or here let's do this
the other way X if y mod 2 equals
z here you can see this is an if else
that is
a that is
a uh expression now uh for the longest
time people have wanted to have some
kind of expression that can bind a
variable name and the reason that they
wanted this is that as follows there are
cases and one of the cases that was
pointed to was regular Expressions you
have some compile from the re module and
you're trying to match some regular
expression so here's my regular
expression
ABC you know here's my pattern and I
want to check to see maybe I have two
patterns so I have pattern one I'll do
Pat one and Pat
two and I have some
text and here I have a BC d f XY Z and I
I want to do something like you know
four line in text. strip.it lines and I
want to say for each of these lines uh
doesn't match this pattern so I'll do
Pat one. Uh full match on the
line I'll do match equals Pat two on the
line and I want to do something here and
I'll say okay did you match this one
okay if this is not none then you match
this one otherwise if you match this one
okay that's good but what if I only
exclusively want to match one of these
two choices and I want to do that in
some order what if I want to match ABC
or DF or something else or there's some
reason why these overlap then I have to
write something really ugly I have to do
the else here okay you didn't match here
and then check that and it starts
getting deeper and deeper and uglier and
uglier as being nested so let's see
let's do an import
as there we go and you can see this just
starts getting deeper and deeper uglier
and uglier as you go and this is full
match without the
underscore there you go so you can see
it matched but I wanted exclusively
match one the other well this was one of
the motivations for creating this
assignment expression What's called the
wallrus operator and so what we do is we
have some expression that we can you
know do normal expression things we can
check it we can perform some other
operation on it and so you can see here
we can do this this is the initial int
intentionality of this and we do an LF
and we can prevent this from being to
for nested now I want to show you one
thing that I like to do with this walrus
operator because that's the canonical
reason but sometimes when I'm creating
like a pandas data frame because I do a
lot of this kind of lightning talk stuff
uh and I do a lot of live coding and I
do a lot of this for corporate training
and for Consulting what I often want to
do is generate some kind of random uh
data frame and one of the ways that I'm
going to generate this just to
illustrate a point about some operation
you can perform on a data frame is I'll
use numpy you know. random and I'll
create a bunch of random onedimensional
numpy and D arrays and so maybe these
will be normal values I'll say x normal
and I have to put the size here and then
I have to do you know Y and Zed and then
later on I'll say you know what I'm
prototyping this I want to make this 10
I want to make that 10 I make that 10
and so I'll say oh why didn't I just do
this and then this here gets ugly and
ugly and I have some line outside maybe
I'm G to cut and paste this block but I
forgot to cut and paste this up here
well why not just use the assignment
expression here so you saw me do this
before here I'll say set the size to
that and
then do that and so here you can see
this gives me a nice simple way bound
within the structure and I can
definitely make this uppercase but it
allows me to cut and paste this block of
text especially if this is like in a
Jupiter notebook or something and move
that around let me show you nope I think
I'm out of time so there you go that's
the assignment expression and one little
helpful case when you're building numpy
and D arrays where this can be
used now moving on we did wallrus our
next one is X array and so I'll restart
my timer and we'll go right into xray
now we are three from the end of this
set of lightning talks and so I would
implore all of you who are watching
please if you have the chance and the
opportunity if you are able please
donate we'd love to meet that stretch
goal we would love to be able to better
support these projects I would love to
not have to give you my Vim RC I think
I'm already obligated to do that but I I
believe in numb focus and I believe in
what we do so much that I'll even show
you my vimrc which I really really don't
want to uh because it's embarrassingly
old and embarrassingly full of junk that
I haven't cleaned out in years but it is
not embarrassing for you to help out the
projects for you to donate and so while
we get to these last three options if
you are watching if you've enjoyed this
if you're having fun if you use the
Projects please $5 $10 reach into your
pocket help us out at numb Focus help us
support the projects better now that
actually was not me stalling for time
because I already know what I want to
tell you about X-ray and I'll tell you
this about x-ray x-ray is a very cool
package unlike numpy which I told you
fundamentally allows you to do something
that python couldn't do that is give you
the ability to manage some constrain
some uh unboxed contiguous machine type
no Dynamic dispatch uh content aware
collection and pandas gives you the
ability to have this buy modality of
lookup you can look things up on two
axes for a data frame buy some index
mechanism so you have some labeled
access and positional access plus a
million additional conveniences xarray
does not ship with compiled code xray
doesn't necessarily give you something
that numpy or pandz or scipi
fundamentally can't give you it gives
you an enormous amount of convenience
wrapped on top of these tools and so
what you'll find when you're using
x-rays you may often use x-ray in
conjunction with numpy and pandas and I
want to show you a quick little example
using xarray xarray provides two
fundamental types the data set and the
data array and the xarray data array is
basically just like a numpy and d array
one of the things that we might do when
we deal with a numpy and drays we might
think of the dimensionality the nump and
Dray being one of the ways that we can
take looping that would exist at a
python level and move it into the into
the restricted computation domain and so
I was recently doing some simulations on
something like a chessboard uh I was I
was trying to say okay what are all the
different ways that a chessboard can be
orientated what are all the different
ways that the pieces on chessboard can
can be situated what are all the
possible end states of a game what are
all the possible beginning states of a
game as just a simple simulation
exercise and since I don't have time to
construct this for you nicely I'll just
use random. choice and or numpy random.
choice so I'll simulate a chessboard and
you could think okay what does a
chessboard look like I'll say a true or
false for a piece being in some space
and I'll say this is of size 8 by8 so
this is my chessboard and when I do that
okay I have a chess board a simulated
chess board this is not particularly
accurate because if I look at this thing
it's probably got way more pieces than
should be should appear on the board 31
pieces that's actually one fewer yeah
one fewer than the actual number of
pieces and when I think about this I
might want to distinguish between the
different pieces so I might say oh there
are six different types of pieces and so
here this I add another layer to this
that represents the pawns the Rooks the
Bishops the Kings sorry the knights the
queen and the king and when I do that I
might I want to simulate the board over
time so maybe I want to simulate 30
steps of this board over time and so
when I have my nump looks like this I
can ask it certain questions like you
can say uh give me the total number of
pieces uh in in the
board for one particular block of time
so here we'll Summit over these axes and
so here you can see for each step of the
game these are total number of pieces
and you can see this is very simulated
so that doesn't really match up but we
don't have the luxury in the remaining
two minutes that we have to actually
pull in real data and I could do other
things like I can say okay give me the
board uh for just the pawns for every
move give me just the
pawns for every position on the board
and then perform some other operation on
this and what xray allows me to do is it
allows me to take this numpy and Dray
allows me to wrap this numpy and D with
some additional accessors with some
addal conveniences one of the major
conveniences is instead of and you can
see all this code still works in instead
of having to access the components of
the nonp array as an unnamed tensor I
can actually access the components of
this NP Andray the different dimensions
in some named fashion I can specify the
dimensions on the structure and you can
think what are the dimensions on this
well this is the move this is the piece
uh this is the x coordinate and this is
the y-coordinate and then notice all of
my code still works except I can now sum
over a dimension I can say sum this over
the pieces the X and the Y and now this
code which you're looking at like axis
one two 3 oh that actually kind of makes
sense you're giving me all the total
pieces for each move for each position
on the board here instead of doing
something like this I could do a
selection on this and I could say select
for piece equals zero for the pawn but
that's not going to work because oh that
will work actually but it's not going to
work for me because what I want to do
instead is I want to give this a
coordinate system and so for the pieces
there's actually a coordinate system
here there's Pawn Rook
Knight
Bishop queen and
king like that and so once I have a
coordinate system on this I can say oh
give me all of these for the pawn and
once I do that I can also do some fancy
things like I can say give me all the
Pawns in
position position xal 3 and yal 4 or xal
3 and 4 and yal 4 and six in that nice
little Cube for every move in the game
how about that that's what X-ray gives
you okay I think we're on to our second
to the end and I could give I want to
give you one more plea we're so close to
the end of this series we're so close to
the end this Teton it's the first time
we've done a Teleton help Teton help us
meet our goal we got two more lightning
talks to go reach into your pocket see
what you can do let's talk about yield
from I will restart
my timer and let's go well yield from
was added to python uh as a delegation
from a sub generator I believe is what
it's called and there were a couple of
things that were added in Python uh that
you know don't really work anymore one
of the one of the cute things that I
used to show people was um if you had a
list that looked like
this it used to be the case in earlier
versions of python and let's see if I
actually have the docor set up to do
this used to be the case so you could do
the following y's equals none for G in
X's actually let me call this G here
here because I used to write this a very
specific way none for G and X's if yield
from G and false so this is how we used
to do this and we'll call this G here
this is some generator and here I'll
print out the results of
this and what I'll do is I'll put this
into a comprehension this won't
unfortunately work anymore you can't put
a yield inside a list comprehension but
I believe if I can run this Docker run
it
no Docker run python 3.5
maybe oh oh do I have I have three
minutes let's see if I can pull in this
Docker container in the time that I have
I'll show you this actually used to work
in Python 3.5 it's almost there it's
coming that syntax actually used to work
and it only stopped working fairly
recently it turns out that yield from
delegation to a sub generate can be used
in some weird used to be able to be used
in some weird places and so let's see if
that worked uh it's coming up in just a
moment oh let it come up and okay let's
see I think I gota and I gotta run this
with probably
it whoops let's do this with a let's do
this with a Docker run it python 3.5 is
what I did pretty sure that'll work
there we go and the code I had was uh g
equals 1 two 3 4 56
and what I thought was kind of neat
about this was if you do what was it
none for G and G if yield from G and
false this used to work and what this
would give you if you flatten this or if
you yeah for
change yeah okay and if you took a look
at this
thing what you would see is it would
flatten the list it was the same thing
as writing G for G and G G for g& G for
g& which is the same thing as writing
from iter tools import chain chain star
G like that and so these are other ways
that we used to flatten list and you
used to be able to use yield from inside
the list comprehensive syntax you
unfortunately can't do that anymore uh
and it really upsets me because I used
to love this little this little trick
what yield from is typically used for is
you sometimes would have a generator and
what that generator would want to do is
it would want to do something like this
let's say we'd say uh four x and x's and
you'd want to do something like yield
you want to yield like this you want to
yield inside one of these generators and
so what yield from will do is it will
allow you to perform these kind of
flattening operation so that a generator
can say okay I'm going to delegate to
another generator and it'll take up for
me so I think I can simulate this for
you pretty easily let's do
this let's have this yield one yield two
and yield three I can also do a yield
from and I can yield from pretty much
anything so I can do
that so here you go you can see a little
bit about what this behavior is and yep
there you go so you can see this is very
similar to the yield star in JavaScript
what it's doing is it's saying don't
yield this structure as a structure
itself go into that structure and yield
each individual element so this thing
happened to be another generator so
let's do
this
here like
that so if this happen to be another
generator you'll see what this does okay
ifn there you go so you can see this is
this used to be very helpful for a
cursive generator that's why it came up
in my pre-order and post-order traversal
okay there we go I think that's yield
from for you and I believe we are now at
zip the end of our list
of things that we want to look at and so
I must implore you in the last five
minutes that we have together this is
your last opportunity to give your last
opportunity to support the projects I
hope you've enjoyed watching me sweat
and suffer this has not been easy yeah I
do this all day for work but uh the
pressure and the time constraints are
pretty intense and I wrote a bunch of
typos I'm absolutely shocked that more
than 10% of the code actually worked
here is what I will offer you if we can
get up to I want to say
$2,250 I don't know if we can make it to
our stretch goal of 2,500 but if we get
up to
$2,250 I will take all of the notes for
all of the lightning talks and I will
put them on Twitter I'll tweet them out
for you so you can see all the notes for
all the the things that I've written and
if we manage to get to that stretch goal
of
$2,500 I'll even clean them up and put
some extra text around them so you can
actually make heads or tails of what the
heck I did but without further Ado let
me show you the very last thing that I
am going to be live coding for our num
Focus 2020 ton zip let's talk about
Zip Zip is
a it tool in the standard in the in the
standard Library so sorry zip is in the
builtins it's a buil-in function that
allows you to take two structures and
pair them up and uh one of the
interesting things that comes up when
you think about zip is if I take a
structure and I zip it with itself I get
itself twice so if I take x one two and
three and I zip it with itself then I
just get one one two two three and 3
three and one interesting thing comes up
when I do this which is if I take a
structure and I zip it not with itself
but with itself offset by some amount by
one then I get a pair wise view so I get
one two two three and so here this gives
me some window view and if I zip it with
itself offset by two like this and this
one offset by zero like this this gives
me paired views or actually Windows of
size three of this structure and so what
that means is what I could do is I could
go into iter tools and I could grab I
slice and T and I'll grab T because I
want to do this on a generator which
doesn't have the ability to rewind to
previous States because it's just that
iterable and it has that uh GI frame
fast ey that we saw you can't get
previous values back out so you have to
te it you have to make transparent
buffered copies if I take a generator
and I te it n times and I enumerate
those things and I slice each one of
these from some index to the
end then I get one of my favorite little
helper functions because I can zip these
things together and this is what I like
to call NYS and what NYS is is the
ability to get very high you know very
low overhead or very very very um I'd
say high performance but nothing in pure
python is really that high performance
but very high
performance views of any structure of
data that I can iterate over up to an
including generators any kind of
stream and I can get them as windowed
views of any size that I want so there
you go now this is not where this ends
because it is often the case that I want
to Loop over something and do something
special for the top of the loop and do
something special for the last element
of the loop and when you think about
that well I can do that in it tools
pretty easily so I have a another helper
function I'd like to write called First
and what first does is it repeats the
value true n times it repeats the value
false infinitely it chains these
together
and it zips that with some generator and
so that was my n wise I also have a
little helper called First and what it
can do ab
bcde and let's actually make this
ABCDE and here what I can do is I can
look at these values and I can indicate
which of them is the first value it's
kind of like en numerate except instead
of giving me the index it gives
me it gives me whether it's the first
value or not and when I do that I might
think well you know what now that I have
first wouldn't it be helpful for me to
have last well what I'm going to do is
I'm going to write ny's longest and I'm
not going to use zip for this I'm going
to use zip longest and the reason I'm
going to do that is when you do this ZIP
trick to in order to look at something
and to look at pairs of something you
also kind of have the ability to look
into the future or to look into the past
that's why this ZIP and this NYSE comes
up so often anytime I write some code
that at the program structuring level
needs look into the future look into the
past then I tend to use zip for that and
I tend to use my NYSE trick well I'm
going to write zip longest I'm going to
give it a fill value and I'll give that
fill value some Sentinal object so it's
distinguishable from an object that
might be in the underly collection and
last then becomes something quite
straightforward last is just a Lambda or
a function that ny's
longest some generator with one more
step so it can look in the future
extracts these
elements like
this and maybe I'll give this Sentinel
to make this very clear when I'm near
the end and when I'm near the end just
says if this last element is the
Sentinel that I'm near the end and here
you can see I have a very nice little
high
performance structure an iterator that
tells me if I am nearing the last of
some structure without having to
materialize it without having to know
ahead of time how big it is just using
zip and the rest of iner tools here I'm
at the last two here I'm at the last one
here I'm at the last three and I can
combine these together and so what I
often do is I write Loops that look like
this four and I'll do this in this Loop
above four is first is
last previous value current value in uh
first last NYS
ABCD like this and then I'll say if
we're at the first element do something
special if we're at the last element do
something special otherwise if you're in
the middle do something special and this
is all built from it tools and first and
uh ZIP and zip longest and I think
that's the end of our lightning talks
I'm so surprised that I made it all the
way through with only one flub that Q
which is going to keep me up late
tonight I'm G to have to write that and
rewrite that until I can get that to
work but I managed to make it through I
am not breaking a sweat I'm dry as can
be uh it's also 16 degrees in here and I
bathed in deodorant last night or
anti-perspirant but I don't think you
managed to make me sweat I'm sorry
Lauren Daren we're gonna have to try
again next time but even if we didn't me
uh meet our goal of making you sweat we
did meet quite a few of our stretch
goals for fundraising for Num Focus
thank you to everyone who contributed
our final amount right now there's still
time to donate but our amount right now
stands at 2155 And1
so uh we're just uh $100 away well $95
away from that stretch goal that you
announced right in the middle of why
which was uh getting all the notes but
not necessarily cleaned up but all the
notes for all the code that we wrote
that's right that's right so if you want
to see those notes go ahead and uh uh
help us get over the top we're just
trying to get to uh 20
2250 would be did we do we want to tell
the a audience that the reason why all
these went so well was I wrote on my
hand for each finger what I was going to
type out in code which is why the Q
didn't work because I only have 20
fingers and toes and
toes I thought I saw you checking your
foot at some point actually yeah and it
was kind of blur was like Zip zup what
the heck is that yeah well especially
because you were sweating right yeah
were you
sweating no I was not
um fantastic uh Jane why don't you uh uh
tell us a little bit about uh everyone
that we want to thank today yeah well we
had a lot of people come together to
help make this event happen um I first
wanted to thank all of our speakers so
we started off with uh Leah silin we got
to hear from her the executive director
of gome focus um after that we heard
from uh Stefan
vanderwalt um and Wolf Gang
kerzendorf um so thank you to both of
them um also to we heard from Fernando
Perez um Travis Olaf Fant uh Katrina
reel Jeff reeback um and Tom Caswell so
thank you to all of our Our Guest uh
speakers who came to uh to share a
little bit about how num focus is
important to them um and we also want to
thank the audience um for your
participation and uh spending your
Saturday afternoon or evening with us um
we loved the engagement both over
Twitter answering uh trivia questions
and uh of course we very much appreciate
your
donations um so thank you so much for
spending your day with us speaking of
donations I see they're still rolling in
we're at
21751 so thank you for everyone that's
continuing to contribute uh if you lik
what you saw today if you like what you
hear about making science more open more
reproducible more inclusive about
getting better docks for pandas and
things like this um if you like that
even little amounts help and we can try
to get to that stretch goal and even if
you've already made a donation but you
you know want to push us just a little
closer to the stretch goal I recommend
donations of $51 Cent for
501c3 uh if you support 501c3
nonprofits 5001 cents that's the way to
go I love it I love it um I'm getting uh
an announcement about the trivia
question that we asked most recently so
what to word command brings up an Easter
egg poem when using Python and that of
course is the Zen of python and you get
it by typing in import this so you can
try it right now open up your terminal
and if I'm right you can donate $51 Cent
In in honor of num Focus uh our winner
on on Twitter is
hypothesis hypothesis
hypothesis um again I apologize for
everyone that I always inevitably mess
up your name but uh thank you to our
winners and to everyone who participated
in all of our Twitter giveaways and
polls also our uh Lauren I'm told we
just hit
2250 uh somebody wanted to see those
notes I told you in unpolished form so
you're gonna see them just as they are
but yeah I guess I promised
amazing amazing you see I've dressed
down for you as well I'm now in my num
Focus hoodie it's beautiful very casual
yeah very casual and I will point out uh
our numbers did go up just again so now
we're past 2250 we're up a little above
so I have to polish the notes okay my
Saturday is goingon to be ruined now you
only have to polish the notes if we get
to 2500 so your Saturday night may be
safe James I don't know we uh oh uh oh
what am I gonna do with the Saturday
night I don't know Saturday night so if
you want if you want to ruin my Saturday
night if you want to uh make sure those
notes get polished with a little bit of
narrative connected text with a little
bit of explanation what I'm talking
about and maybe I'll fix that Q one
because that really bugs me I probably
would be up late tonight anyway fixing
that one uh let's get to
2500 wow that's a lot I didn't think
we'd be able to get that high yeah and
what's incredible is that you know right
now we're at 20 330 and if you think
about it it's kind of like
4660 because of that year-end match so
your money is going twice as far with
the year-end match that num focus is
offering through their other corporate
sponsors so go ahead and make your
donation now it's going to go twice as
far wow I'm seeing people on the YouTube
chat saying run his Saturday
folks hashtag in the
making what they what they secretly
don't know is that uh I live for this
stuff don't
I don't don't do do I do I not
Lauren well uh yeah yeah you do um but
that's okay I think we all live for Num
Focus we're all here on a Saturday we're
all you know volunteering our time to uh
to make this happen we've got a number
of people that are not volunteering as
well that uh you know this is a
sponsored event from don't use this code
uh but we're here to um you know because
we're part of the community and we want
to give back and uh I I think personally
this is very important I've dedicated
more hours than I should probably admit
to to volunteering for for Num focus in
various capacities and it's all because
I think it's really important right our
future depends on reproducible science
inclusive science open science and these
tools um I think are open open science
tools and open source tools are really
uh you know our best path forward in a
future that is sometimes uh
terrifying to to end on that kind of
note um Jan why don't you say something
more
uplifting I have something I saw that
the El silent who I believe is our
executive director from n Focus um the
moment we mentioned ruin James this
Saturday she reached into her pocket and
found 50 bucks for
that that seems to be a
seller fantastic yeah right now we're at
2455 so we are so close to that final
stretch goal that includes uh uh the
Polish notes from James uh lick the
limmerick don't forget the Limerick I
think we even promised the ram I think
we promised that oh two play is at 2500
too oh and two play two play two play to
play that's a lot you know play or not
to play for $45 I think you guys are
gonna be getting a lot for
that
um yeah that's all I
have I think it's going to be a
lot wow I'm seeing even more donations
coming in so thank you thank you thank
you
everyone um we have our Raffles to
announce as well I think our most common
donor or sorry our most frequent donor
was David Sushi y thank you David for
for uh donating throughout the Stream e
Fox is uh uh uh asking everyone to now
angrily ruin his Saturday come on folks
it is uh kind of your last chance before
we close up this stream and we are so
close for $45
away I'm already writing the limmer
right now are you writing the limmerick
I'm I know I know it's coming I know
it's coming and I want to save my Sunday
no they they want to hear from you live
okay Pon a language that that's
meant wow time to be spent are there any
other Raffles that need to be
announced oh oh I'm getting word that uh
we might have a special guest to bring
back on it looks like Leah is standing
by James should we bring on Leah yeah
let's bring her back for some final
words to thank the audience for this is
amazing we uh we're shocked by the
outpouring of support and it looks like
we are over our 2500 goals so uh
incredible once we talk to Leah uh I
think you're gonna be on the hook for a
lot of things
James Leah if you're there can you turn
on your
camera so as we wait wait for Leah to
get uh uh signed up I'm I'm still
looking in the the chat that we have on
the back end here who was our our
highest
donor um so I want to give a thank you
to
Holden uh for a for our largest donation
of the
night oh no well Holden held it until
just uh recently and then I've see
another one for 500 so maybe we can get
those details um in the the support chat
uh and then uh I can announce that after
Leah speaks hi Leah great to have you
back what do you
think yeah it's been a very fun day
thank you so much this has been
fantastic James congrats you made it
through um yeah Jane and Lauren need an
excellent job and yeah thanks everyone
for their contributions and um yeah I'm
super excited met all the
goals
woohoo James James said woohoo and
you're like sitting there
I'm I would love to hear your thought
process as you write limmerick
so feel free to talk us
through process so this this one's a
little bit rough through casual
working here's what I have so far I'll
share my screen I'll switch over to my
produced
view I don't think we need the timer for
this
one so here's what I have so far uh
Python's a language that's meant to
improve how your time is being spent by
showing your meaning through casual
gleaning and having fun in either event
that's a little rough still I gotta I
gotta Workshop this a
bit that's good that's
impressive better than I did you nums
are very simplistic right they have a
very simplistic meter and a very
simplistic rhyme
scheme okay let me
think so we have to we have to this is
where we need some
scansion
Focus exactly they all sound the same
right It's the Rhythm yeah it's a what
it's a dactylic with a masculine rhyme I
believe
yeah that sounds
good them Focus supports all the
tools supports many
tools so fill the air while I keep
writing because this is not an
interesting process to watch me write a
rck oh but it is I'm I'm fascinated
personal find something to Rhymes at
tool people in the audience are like
looking for rhyming words and trying to
help you cuz I find myself automatically
doing that I
watch if you're still on the the YouTube
live stream if you're still on Twitter
go ahead and tweet at us or send a
comment of uh you know various open
source
Rhymes okay we're we're getting a from
the chat uh num Focus supports many
tools none of you should be fools no see
see the SC doesn't a scan yeah it's got
to have the pentameter or
whatever
yeah oh wow it looks like uh David Sushi
donated uh again so thank you for our
most frequent donor and I would also
like to uh uh call out our highest
donors of the evening so until just a
few moments ago uh Holden caral held the
highest donor slot so so excited to have
support from the spark Community um she
is uh one of the uh uh authors of many
of the spark books and so really excited
to see that Holden is uh here on the
line with us or at least was
earlier um and then uh usurping that
spot until just now we got an amazing
$500 from OSS Capital so thank you OSS
capital for making your last minute
contribution very exciting to see that
we raised so much money for open source
today and so now we're at uh
3170 and oh great even though we met our
our goal you know I can post another one
I can make it go to 5,000 right there's
no reason to feel limited by our most
recent stretch goal uh Dona num to num
focus is a a great cause and a great
place to put your end of your money
so oh it um our are we James while
you're workshopping this were we also
going to do a room reveal I mean I I
think that for you want how I live my
life I don't know that's a that's a bit
much did we hit our Target for that or
do we want to push that up to 5,000
5,000 H I think it's kind of a lot but
if we get to 3500 we'll do the room
reveal meanwhile you'll just uh uh
puzzle through this uh limmer how about
that that one's
hard
the pro the problem is I don't know
enough about science so let's see what
what the the non Focus projects are we
have projects like Tardis which do
Supernova ejecta um we have Cana which
is what thermodynamic simulation we do
have a molecular is that MD analysis
that's a molecular analysis
project what is that I want molecules in
here
somewhere we can do that
molecules uh
supernova hm got to think about that
this is this is always hard you have to
the thing with the limeric is you you
you think about it you dwell on it and
then inspiration hits and it just comes
out uh and so the workshopping process
is kind of finding the rhyme what's
tricky in a really good limeric is
finding the joke you want that through
line with the joke in it
so so let's try something else so really
the process is not that interesting
Focus could use your support
then you have to think what rhymes with
support
uh
exhort so James while you're while
you're puzzling through this I want to
ask Leah again a little bit more about
how this money will help in 2021 right
um there were uh basically all of the
inperson events were canceled this year
right um not just for your organization
but but worldwide everywhere have have
really uh had to switch to Virtual
environments and um I think what did you
have you had a Piata taipe was in person
because they thankfully got things under
control there right that was it yeah
everything else everything else was
moved online everything else was online
Pi data Global was the first ever
virtual Pi data which was really
exciting but um you know I'm sure it was
challenging right so you go from
in-person events to suddenly having to
do these virtual uh events and how how
can money raised tonight help um you
know the projects in 2021 and also the
educational mission of num focus in
2021 it's going to help um 2021 and I'm
um working on that that budget right now
which is uh a little bit challenging
because we don't know what events are
going to look like for 2021 and we also
just don't know our um corporate
sponsorships you know it was a challenge
ing year for everyone across the board
um both nonprofit organizations as well
as um you know seen all across industry
in many cases so um our corporate
donations were down a bit as well as um
as well as taking a hit on on the
project so um we were carefully watching
dollars this year and that makes it a
little bit challenging moving into the
next year because we're trying to
project and focus those so um having
funds to be able to know uh you know we
can apply those towards our small
development grant program is super
helpful we try to do a uh at least a
20,000 um Dollar Jump every year for
small development grants it's to be
really challenging this year but um but
we'd love to um get that get that up to
like
175 um for next year we hate to turn
projects down for small development
grants so we're hoping that um yeah it'd
be nice to be able to um you know have
the money to be able to um see that
increase next
year and it was great to hear Tom and
and Jeff and everyone um that came on
mentioned the small development grants
it's so important people don't realize
how important $5,000 can be to a project
and you think oh that's nothing we
should be able to get $5,000 for these
um projects but like I said we did 150
this year and there were still projects
that unfortunately um we weren't able to
fund all all the
request W yeah I think a lot of people
don't realize that even though as a user
of Open Source like the software is free
to download you know it doesn't mean
that it's just free out of nowhere all
up and down you know the the chain right
like somewhere someone is incurring a
cost uh free software isn't free in that
sense um it actually takes a lot of
money uh to support these things in the
background and to make sure that the
Strategic improvements that are needed
to maintain the projects um is really
important right because I I think it was
uh Jeff reback that said you know if
python keeps advancing but the projects
don't then you know it's uh you you lose
the maintainability of something that is
very very critical to a lot of people's
work
right and so num focus is um really
important in that you know the projects
can't take grants directly to themselves
like just like Tom was saying it's not
like when Matt plot lib needs something
he's able to just uh you know get that
money in his a bank account and take
care of it right uh uh they need that
sort of tax free status and that type of
government and the financial structure
is what num Focus provides to the
projects to help provide a source of um
you know collecting these types of funds
like we did today uh that are uh not
earmarked for anything in particular
that can then go directly to the
projects as needs arise in a very
strategic way exactly and to make sure
those services are in place that they
all need that we can continue to provide
those and I love that I I felt we heard
a a pretty consistent message today from
some of our speakers about the ways in
which num Focus helps to sort of hone
developer enthusiasm for working on open
source um in that you know we have a lot
of really talented developers out there
that are excited about contributing to
open source and they they freely give
their time in most cases um you know
basically volunteering and creating
tools that then the rest of the world
can use um but that sometimes you know
some know even small amount of financial
incentive is really helpful for people
who you know need to live um so that's
that's incredibly helpful um and then
also the fact that you know as Tom
Caswell mentioned um that at the end of
the day there are always tiny parts of a
project that you know people don't want
to have to deal with um whether that's
you know the accounting or the
advertising some people you know are
really enthusiastic about uh a
particular part of a project but um
there are always going to be things that
need to get done that maybe nobody wants
to take on and by um having num Focus
there to sort of Step Up and and help
out with um maybe some of those tasks to
kind of keep the infrastructure going
and and and keep things working um those
developers who again are volunteering
their time to create these awesome tools
uh are sort of freed up so that they can
focus on the parts that they really
enjoy yeah and I know for me personally
like being part of the open source
Community has really been a benefit to
my career right I think Katrina was
saying something similar that you know
you can see other people's code you can
interact directly with the developers
and you have a a community behind you of
um people that are all working towards a
similar goal I think it's very very
valuable and particularly to the time
that I have spent volunteering for Num
focus in my capacity as uh Pata New York
chair in 2018 and
2019 uh volunteering for Piata Global in
2020 20 I think all of these things it
really makes you feel like you're a
member of the community and um and it it
becomes your network right it really
helps you out so I I'm incredibly
thankful to numb focus and it's you know
frankly an honor that we got to spend
this time today raising some money um
for for a cause that I believe in very
strongly yeah I agree and the
communities it's an incredible Community
to um be a part of I'm very grateful
that um I'm able to work with um and get
to just talk you know and work with on a
daily basis some incredible people both
the staff at nfocus all the project
leads users that we meet at events
volunteers um yeah that's why coming up
on um yeah nine years later I'm still
here so very in incredible
Community have I really known you for
nine years geez it's a long time coming
we're coming up to that that
point yeah yeah James how's the limmer
going I don't know see lims are a tricky
thing I say when it's when in
Inspiration strikes you and you have to
find that thread or that through line
one of the things I liked about support
as the the rhyme was that you could
rhyme it against import which has that
dual meaning and I think a limeric is
very good when it has some kind of
hidden or dual meaning behind it and so
I'm still workshopping this it's still
taking me a while this is what I have to
start with um
I also kind of like the idea of trying
to work the project names into it uh but
it's still a little rough and so this is
going to take me a while let's see where
we are in the donations let see if I'm
on the hook to really wrap this up and
come up with limmerick number two or
whether folks are happy with what we
have so far because I'm in it for the
long haul let's see if the folks at home
are
too yeah so uh currently we've raised
3170 and 1
cent um which is really
exciting it's excellent that is
excellent it's yeah I I think it was a
fantastic way to spend a Saturday
afternoon are you still thinking about
that Limer I'm trying to read it
am could you read it for us James yeah
what we have uh there's a couple
different ones I as I said I like the I
like the import I like the Dual The
Duality here of you know this thing that
we do in Python all the time and the the
meaning of this as being important uh
and I was thinking is there a way I can
put the names of the projects in there
despite me I really hate it when people
import as really bugs me um but you know
whenever you PD import remember to NF
support our projects for scarning and
then I can't get to the next line that's
a little tricky I think uh rhyming with
scar is a little a little bit hard uh
and then you'd have to Ren sigh your
wallet uh then we have to find another
rhyme see the import's a little tricky
because you got to find three rhyming
words with it just to uh just to make
that work and so part of the limeric
process is also funny what that last
rhyme is so it's not too sing songy like
you know there's a lot of songs that
people you know you hear a lot of really
bad pop songs and you have these really
simplistic uh rhyme schemes at the end
like you know B and and things like that
you need to find something a little bit
richer than that
but getting just the right rhyme is
where you start so I'd say if there's a
process behind it is really figuring out
what that main rhyme is going to be and
the rest comes together from there and
even though I like that import I don't
know if I can do anything with it
because there's really such such little
that you can do you do import support
exort
comport but comport is a little bit a
little bit lofty for
Limer
um let me think let me try something
else so it's 26 lightning talks and a
live limeric yeah an a live limmerick
uh what a
bonus and our goal we're hitting we're
trying to hit
four is 35 just so that we can wrap up
for
today
yeah I mean I think we we hit our goals
a number of times I I've uh I've bumped
it up to 3500 but I think you know
actually at this point if this were real
life I would have like a big check and I
would hand it over to Leah it would say
3170 and one cent and we'd all go
yay we did it because you know
originally the goal for this was 750
bucks right and we blew past that and I
think that this has been really an
incredible celebration
of of everyone um well not everyone you
know we could make it bigger but
everyone in the open source Community
coming together and I I do hope that we
can do this again I hope we can do this
bigger and better next time um uh you
know trying to plan this uh was an event
in and of itself and so I think probably
we'll release some of the behind the
scenes footage should you guys uh be
interested um but yeah I hope next time
we can get even more of the project
represented uh someone in the YouTube
chat even said you know it's really the
less glamorous parts of numfocus support
that benefit the most right it's really
the like the it's easy to find
volunteers for the things that are
glamorous but it's the the kinds of
things that are really hard to do or or
the projects that are a little bit more
Niche that are still incredibly
important but it's hard to get the the
support that you need unless we have
these kinds of funds for it so um I
don't know on that note like Leah thank
you so much for for joining us this
morning joining us now this evening at
least my local time your local time as
well and um I I think we can can wrap it
up thank you so much everyone that
participated in this today and when you
say everybody who participated you don't
just mean Jane and Leah and all of our
special guests but all of the folks
watching from home if you didn't donate
just watching just helping us have a fun
time talk about the projects talk about
what we do with these projects talk
about what num Focus does all of you are
included in this great success we all
did it together thank you so much this
is why I wasn't worried this is why I
didn't sweat because I knew that you all
were there supporting us as you have
been supporting num focus and the
projects for years it's been a rough
year for many of us it's been a
difficult year for Num Focus it's been a
difficult year for folks throughout the
world we are truly blessed to be where
we are we are truly blessed to have a
community of users like all of you at
home who
are willing to help us support the
projects make science better and make
the world a better place thank you
all and thank you to my co-hosts uh Jane
for helping me out here and uh for uh uh
having the same Christmas kind of Lights
in the background as me and uh the hats
and the glasses and the gimmicks it was
really a lot of fun um thanks so much
for having me
um James there's an a request that you
read the limmer out loud as it is
written uh this is everyone's final
reminder to donate if you have a chance
if you got five bucks in your pocket go
ahead and and put it in the Donate
button
um I believe we announced the Raffle
winners did we announce the Raffle
winners if we need to we will or we'll
follow up on Twitter and we'll follow up
on Twitter with my Vim config cleaned up
cleaned up notes that's right uh Tom's
em RC MH
um what else do we have the color map
the number m is gonna get committed for
a poll
request and uh you know continue the
conversation here on Twitter uh or using
hash cjam sweat you could say I saw
James sweat but then it's gonna mess up
the
hashtag yeah thanks thanks to everyone
again we're incredibly grateful and um
James yeah want to hear you hope all
have fun I help you no we're not getting
off until you read the limeric and then
that's it then I'm goingon to go back to
my first one I think that's the best I
have I'm GNA have to Noodle on this for
the rest of the day uh some things come
easy when you do them enough like live
coding some things you got to really
noodle until inspiration strikes like
poetry I'm going to stick with the first
one that I have but over the next couple
of days I'm going to let this sit in the
back of my mind and maybe maybe I might
have something for you in a couple of
days when we post all of the other
goodies that we have for you and I'll do
that for free because I want to support
y'all and I want y'all to have fun I
want you to enjoy yourself just as much
as we've all enjoyed ourselves today so
I'll stick with the first one that I
wrote inspiration struck I think it's
okay maybe needs a little bit of
workshopping but we all know that our
Julie and python Fantastic Tools I
happen to like python that's what I use
today and I like python because it's a
language that's meant to improve how my
time's being spent to show my all my
meaning through casual gleaning and have
fun in either event thank you
everybody thank you bye
everyone
[Music]
were remember you would say it was going
to change but it's hard to fake
now